nous allons poursuivre l'examen de
l'avis des missions budgétaires relevant
de notre commission avec l'examen des
missions justice et nous sommes ravis de
recevoir à nouveau monsieur le garde des
saau pour présenter votre premier budget
depuis le vote définitif de la loi
d'orientation de programmation du
ministère de la justice c'est est un
exercice assez redondant avec ce que
nous avons fait la fois précédente
c'est-à-dire cet été alors avecos après
vos interventions interviendons deux
rapporteurs pour avis c'était madame
tanzili qui devait intervenir mais je
crois qu'elle est malade et retenue pour
cela monsieur le rapporteur TER qui l'
supplait euh pour la mission justice et
accès au droit et Monsieur rapporteur
pouliia pour l'administration
pénitentiaire et la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse comme vous le
savez c'est un orateur par groupe
ensuite pour une durée de 4 minutes et
ensuite oui madame je vous ai vu et
ensuite les députés qui posent une
question le peuvent le faire pour 2
minutes monsieur camardine également je
vous inscris après vos réponses on
examinera les amendements hors la
présence du garde des saau et les
crédits qui feront chacun l'objet de
vote monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole devant la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale merci merci
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
euh monsieur le rapporteur pour avis
monsieur le rapporteur pour avis madames
mesdames messieurs les députés je
partage votre sentiment monsieur le
Président de la Commission des LO c'est
un exercice un peu un peu redondant et
c'est doucement euphémique que de le
rappeler bon je suis très heureux de
vous présenter pour la 4e année le temps
passe vite euh le projet de budget du
ministère la justice alors pour 2024 cet
exercice évidemment s'inscrit dans un
contexte particulier puisque vous venez
d'adopter définitivement la loi
d'orientation et de programmation pour
la
justice cette loi permet de
péréniser les hausses de moyens pour
renforcer notre notre justice en la
rendant plus proche plus protectrice
plus rapide pour chaque chacun de nos
concitoyens et l'enjeu pour moi
aujourd'hui est d'abord de vous montrer
comment concrètement le gouvernement
tient les engagements qu'il prend devant
vous et devant les
Français je vous confirme donc que le
projet de budget 2024 pour le ministère
de la Justice respecte à la lettre la
trajectoire budgétaire que nous donne la
loi de programmation conformément à
l'engagement du président de la
République à la volonté de la première
ministre et grâce au soutien du ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics
l'ambition de ce nouveau budget est
d'abord d'améliorer la
qualité de la justice qui doit être
rendue au justiciables et donc à tous
nos
compatriotes venant s'ajouter à des
années d'augmentation ayant permis au
budget du ministère de passer de
6,9 milliards d'euros en 2017 à
9,6 milliards d'euros en 2023 la la
hausse se poursuivra en
2024 sans se payer de mots on peut dire
que c historique le projet de budget de
la justice que je vous soumet dépasse la
barre symbolique des 10 milliards
d'euros pour atteindre
10,1 milliards d'euros entre 2023 et
2024 ça représente une hausse de près
d'un demi milliard d'euros
supplémentairire 503 millions
précisément soit près de
5,3 %
d'augmentation rien que pour les
rémunérations versées aux agents du
ministère hors cotisation retraite
l'enveloppe va passer de
4,7 milliards en 2023 à
5,1 milliards en
2024 soit une hausse parmi les plus
importantes qu' connu le ministère une
hausse de près de 8 %. c'est la
traduction directe Mesdames et Messieurs
les Députés et concrète de ma politique
de ressources humaines des recrutements
massifs conjugués à une forte
revalorisation des
rémunérations et que les choses soient
claires le défi de ce ministère pour les
4 années à venir ne sera pas de savoir
si nous allons recruter plutôt de savoir
comment nous allons réussir à pourvoir
la totalité des nouveaux emplois que
nous allons créer d'où
l'importance s'il vous
plaît non non non s'il vous
plaît d'où
l'importance monsieur le député
camardine à côté des recrutements que
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion d'annoncer de
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers de
la justice je rappelle qu'au terme de la
loi de programmation
2027 le budget du ministère frolllera
les 11 milliards d'euros à l'échelle des
deux quinquenas du président de la
République le budget du ministère sera
passé de 6,9 milliards d'euros à près de
en 2017 à près de 11 milliards en 2027
soit une hausse de près de 60 %. dans le
détail ces moyens importants permettront
d'alimenter chacune des grandes
composantes du ministère pour lesquelles
les hausses annuelles de crédit hors
cotisation retraite je le redis
évolueront de la manière suivante plus
12 % pour les services judiciaires pour
atteindre 3,8 milliards d'euros en 2024
contre les 3,4 milliards en
2023 de façon pluriannuelle depuis mon
arrivée en 2020 le budget des services
judiciaires aura connu une hausse
d'environ 30 % passant de 3,5 milliards
en 2020 à
4,5 milliards en 2024 y compris
cotisation retraite 2èmement
stabilisation du budget de
l'administration pénitentiaire en 2024
par rapport à 2023 soit un budget de 3,9
milliards d'euros la progression du
budget de la DAP reprendra en 2025 à la
faveur de la dernière vague de mise en
chantier des établissements restants du
plan immobilier
pénitentiaire plus 3 % au bénéfice de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
athignen atteignant donc pardonnez-moi
950 millions pour 2024 contre
922 millions en
2023 plus 9 % pour le secrétariat
général du ministère passant ainsi de
642 millions en 2023 à 702 millions en
2024 2024 sera donc une nouvelle étape
majeur dans le rattrapage de plus de 30
ans d'abandon
budgétaire politique et humain de notre
justice
auquel notre président
de la République a décidé de mettre un
coup d'arrêt je dis souvent qu'on ne
répare pas un tel abandon en un
claquement de doigt mais nous sommes sur
le bon chemin 2021 2022 23 24 l'année
change mais mesdames et messieurs les
députés le cap reste le même restaurer
la place de la justice à la hauteur des
missions
fondamentales qui euh est la sienne à la
hauteur de l'engagement de ceux qui la
servent et surtout et surtout à la
hauteur de des attentes des Français au
nom de qui nous ne pouvons pas l'oublier
la justice est rendue il est essentiel
que de manière très concrète ces hausses
budgétaires puissent directement
améliorer le fonctionnement de la
justice comme d'ailleurs nous commençons
à le percevoir grâce au moyen d'ors et
déjà déployé lors des précédentes lois
de
finances pardonnez-moi je veux prendre
un seul exemple les délais les délais de
justice alors j'ai
fixé un objectif lors de la présentation
du plan d'action pour la justice celui
de réduire drastiquement tous ces délais
ça passe par la réduction des stocks
d'affaires et je soulligne d'ailleurs
que nous avons obtenu grâce au moyens et
à l'engagement de nos magistrats greffi
contractuel une baisse des stocks allant
jusqu'à 30 % selon les matières et les
juridictions et
ce dans la période comprise entre le 1er
janvier 2021 et la fin 2022 et je
rappelle d'ailleurs d'un mot que nous
mettrons en place au 1er novembre une
politique de l'amiable qui vise
également et notamment à réduire ses
délais en matière civile je veux être
clair il faut naturellement que nous
allions encore plus loin que chacun
prenne toute sa part à cet effort
collectif parce que les Français ne
comprendraient pas que l'État consacre
autant d'argent à notre justice et vous
savez à quel point je me suis battu pour
obtenir ces budgets sans que ces moyens
n'amélior concrètement le service public
de la justice qui leurit rendu les
efforts des contribuables nous obligent
à des résultats ces résultats ne
pourront être atteints qu'avec la
mobilisation de tous les acteurs du
monde judiciaire ont pu compter sur moi
pour décrocher ses budgets historiques
et sur le Parlement et notamment la
majorité mais pas que pour les voter je
sais que nous pouvons compter sur eux
pour que ces moyens tant attendus et
mérités au regard de l'engagement de
tous ceux qui servent notre justice et
rapidement mesdames et messieurs les
députés des effets concrets pour les
justiciable c'est un impératif il en va
de la crédibilité de notre justice aux
yeux
de tous les Français mesdames et
messieurs s'agissant maintenant des
emplois la priorité de ce budget 2024
est d'accélérer le rythme de recrutement
pour tenir le cap fixé par la loi de
programmation qui prévoit la création de
10000 emplois supplémentaires sur ce
quinquena et nous dépasserons ainsi en
2027 la barre des 100000 personnel au
sein de ce
ministère afin de conserver une certaine
flexibilité ces 100000 emplois seront
répartis année après année en fonction
bien sûr des besoins métiers de
l'avancement des projets et des
capacités de recrutement et de formation
des écoles comme le prévoit la loi de
programmation la loi d'orientation et de
programmation nous créerons 1500 postes
de magistrats supplémentaires
et 1800 postees de greffiers
supplémentaires sur ce quinquenin par
ailleurs entre 2023 et
2025 1000 100 attachés de justice seront
recrutés afin de créer une véritable
équipe autour du
magistrat pour lui permettre de se
concentrer sur son cœur de métier dire
le droit trancher les litiges et bien
sûr rendre la justice et permettez-moi
un instant d'insister sur un point qui
n'a pas toujours été bien compris
notamment au cours des débats
parlementaires soit que je n'ai pas été
suffisamment explicite soit que certains
n'ont pas voulu entendre concernant ces
créations il s'agit de création nette
nette
d'emploi comme leur nom le suggère ce
sont des créations netes je le redis et
autrement dit elles viennent en plus du
remplacement de tous les départs à la
retraite et je prends un exemple la
création de
1500 postes de magistrat supplémentaires
va en réalité nécessiter le recrutement
de près de
2800 magistrats pour compenser
2800 et je l'ai dit à l'instant les
départs en retraite
seront évidemment pris en compte les
chiffres que je vous annonce ne sont pas
des chiffres en trompeleuil ils
représente une augmentation concrète
précise vérifiable des effectifs dans
les juridiction par rapport à
aujourd'hui enfin j'ai eu l'occasion
d'annoncer la répartition géographique
par cours d'appel de ces renforts
judiciaires le 31 août dernier lors
du discours de Colmar avec par exemple
91 magistrats supplémentaires sur le
ressort de
doué au moins 127 greffiers
supplémentaires sur le ressort de
Versailles ou encore 72 attachés de
justice d'ici
2025 sur le ressort d'exen Provence je
rappelle que cette première répartition
géographique
traduit deux principes fond
d'une part
l'objectivité la répartition nationale
entre cours d'appel tient compte bien
sûr de plusieurs critères
objectifs niveau des stocks évolution du
nombre
d'affaires sur les 10 dernières années
évolution de la délinquence données
socio-économiques démographique et
d'autre
part la confiance dans les acteurs de
terrain pour ce qu'on appelle le dernier
kilomètre j'ai souhaité en effet que la
répartition au sein de chaque cour
d'appel reviennent au chef de cours afin
de répartir ses efforts historiques au
plus près des besoins des juridictions
de leur ressort qu'ils connaissent en
réalité mieux que quiconque maintenant
madames et
Messieurs les Députés concernant
précisément l'année
2024 une
aisation de recrutement maximal de 2110
ETP en plus des remplacements des
départs à la retraite a été accordé au
ministère pour comparaison avec les
créations nettes d'emploi qui sont
faites par l'État au global le ministère
de la Justice représentera près du
tiers de tous les agents publics
recrutés en 24 pour rappel en 2022 720
emplois avaient été créés par le
ministère de la Justice nous avons
triplé ce chiffre en 2023 et les
créations se maintiendront à ce niveau
exceptionnel en 2024 ces 200
2110 personnels seront répartis de la
façon
suivante
1307 ETP pour la justice judiciaire avec
notamment 327 magistrats
140 non pardon 327 magistrats 340
greffiers 400 attachés de justice parmi
ces personnels 33 seront plus
spécifiquement alloués au renforcement
des capacités de formation de l'ENM dont
22 magistrats vous savez que le nm
tourne à plein et après une précédente
promotion historique nous aurons encore
une nouvelle promotion historique au
point que le nm sur le plan bâtimentaire
a été obligé d'aller déménager dans un
autre quartier de Bordeaux le centre
historique le site historique restera là
où il est mais nous avons été obligés
pour accueillir les futurs auditeurs de
justice de d'envisager d'autres d'autres
locaux jusqu'à 599 personnels pour
l'administration pénitentière dont
notamment 512
surveillants ce quantom comprend une
possibilité de rattrapage de 149 ETP
procédant d'une sous-exécution
antérieure l'École Nationale de
l'Administration Pénitentiaire quant à
elle sera renforcée de trois emplois
supplémentaires
92 ETP pour la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse le reste soit 112 personnel
bénéficiera à la coordination de la
politique publique de la justice et plus
particulièrement au secrétariat
général mesdames et messieurs les
députés s'agissant maintenant des
rémunération nous renforçons
l'attractivité des métiers de justice
afin de pouvoir assurer ce niveau inédit
de
recrutement les rémunérations
participent évidemment bien sûr de cette
attractivité à titre comparatif je
rappelle que à mon arrivée en 2020
l'enveloppe catégorielle servante à
revaloriser les professionnels de ce
ministère était de 17 millions d'euros
avant de passer à 50 millions par an en
2021 et
2022 puis 110 millions en
2023 dont
80 millions de mesures nouvelle pour
2024 j'ai le plaisir d'annoncer que
cette enveloppe catégorielle augmente à
nouveau
significativement afin d'atteindre un
montant de plus de
170 millions d'euros dont 64 millions de
mesures nouvelles ceci
représente une multiplication par 10
depuis mon arrivée cette progression
inédite nous engage par ailleurs les
crédits interministériels permettront de
financer les mesures catégorielles
issues de la conférence salariale du 12
juin 2023 à hauteur de 33 millions pour
le ministère de la Justice ces mesures
permettront principalement l'injection
de 5 points d'indice supplémentaire pour
l'ensemble des agents du ministère et ce
dès le 1er janvier 2024 afin de prendre
en considération la hausse de
l'inflation s'agissant des grandes mesur
de revalorisation qui seront financé
cette enveloppe catégorielle de 170
millions pour 2024 se répartira de la
façon
suivante concernant les magistrats comme
annoncé l'année dernière une
revalorisation inédite a été mise en
place depuis le 1er octobre 23
atteignant 1000 € brut par mois et par
magistrat en moyenne je vous l'annonce
elle sera
effective sur les payes versées ce
vendredi cette mesure représente un
effort budgétaire de
88,5 millions d'euros en 2024 elle est
nécessaire évidemment pour maintenir
l'attractivité de ce métier et pour
aligner la rémunération des magistrats
de l'ordre judiciaire avec les
rémunérations de leurs collègues de
l'ordre
administratif cette mesure est légitime
pour
témoigner toute notre
reconnaissance à l'égard des magistrats
qui au quotidien au service de la
justice de notre pays d'ailleurs leur
régime indemnitaire n'avait pas été
augmenté à part quelques revalorisation
spécifique à certaines fonctions depuis
1996 concernant les surveillants
pénitentiaires et les officiers j'ai
annoncé en février dernier compté du 1er
janvier 2024 les surveillants pénitentia
passeront en catégorie B tandis que les
officiers passeront en catégorie A avec
des revalorisations
indiciè et indemnitaire en parallèle
alors que les contours de cette réforme
seront bientôt tracés je peux déjà dire
qu'en terme budgétaire 47 millions
seront sanctuir
pour financer ces mesures il s'agit je
le rappelle aujourd'hui devant vous
d'une réforme inédite
essentielle pour recruter reconnaître
l'importance des métiers pénitentiaires
et prendre en compte la complexité et la
difficulté croissante de leur mission je
porte la même attention aux autres
fonctionnaires de ce ministère qui ne
seront pas oublié avec en particulier la
revalorisation indiciaire et
indemnitaire
de la filière GREF à hauteur de 15
millions d'euros première étape d'une
réforme approfondie de ce corps la
poursuite des mesures transverses porté
par le Secrétariat général à hauteur de
15,5 million d'euros des mesures en
faveur des corps spécifiques de la PJJ
pour 3 million d'euros et enfin une
revalorisation des corps de direction de
la DAP et des personnes du service
national du renseignement pénitentiaire
à hauteur de 1 million d'euros par
ailleurs complément de cet enveloppe
162 170 millions d'euros une mesure de
revalorisation des magistrats ainsi
qu'une mesure catégorielle
complémentaire en faveur des greffiers
sera octroyé avec une enveloppe pouvant
atteindre
22,5 million d'euros en 2024 pour les
greffes
cette mesure s'accompagnera d'une
réforme statutaire
d'envergure articulée autour de trois
axes en premier lieu la restructuration
du corps de greffier de catégorie B qui
permettra une accélération de leur
carrière et un accès plus ouvert à
l'échelon somital de greffier principal
ensuite la création d'un corps de
greffier de catégorie A d'une volumétrie
de
3200 agents qui permettra la
reconnaissance de l'expertise des
greffiers sur leur mission
juridictionnelle notamment greffi
principaux et
fonctionnel enfin un plan pluriannuel de
requalification des agents de catégorie
C faisant fonction de griffier qui
permettra là encore la reconnaissance
des compétences de ces métiers
indispensa à la justice sans attendre la
la mise en œuvre de la nouvelle grille
indicière annoncée le 12 septembre
dernier je rappelle qu'alors qu'un
greffier en milieu de carrière sur des
missions classiques percevait au 31
décembre
2021 2312 € brut mensuel traitement de
base plus prime il perçoit aujourd'hui
2606 € ce qui représente une
augmentation de 294 € brut par mois soit
une progression mensuelle de sa
rémunération de 13 % en matière de
revalorisation mon CAP est très clair il
est celui de l'attractivité de tous les
métiers de la justice et de la
fidélisation des femmes et des hommes
qui travaillent au service de la justice
de notre pays
c'est un enjeu de reconnaissance de leur
engagement
monsieur le rapporteur pour ravis pouya
s'agissant de la programmation
immobilière pénitentiaire ces crédits
permettront de poursuivre le plan de
construction voulu par le Président de
la République pour mémoire ce plan
portera plus de
75000 le nombre total de places de
prison disponi à l'horizon 2027 en
érigeant 51 nouveaux établissements
pénitentiaires je suis pleinement engagé
et fin 2024 nous aurons réalisé la
moitié du chemin avec 23
établissements opérationnels sur les 51
établissements que compte cette
programmation immobilière plus
précisément concernant
2023 ce sont 11 établissements qui
auront été mis en service je m'y étais
engagé devant vous l'année dernière le
mont les croisettes inauguré le 24 avril
connais en Nouvelle-Calédonie
qui a ouvert en février les SAS de
Montpellier et de camp celle de Valence
d'Avignon inauguré en juillet dernier la
nouvelle prison de C if inaugurée le 6
octobre par la première ministre ainsi
qu'un nouveau quartier de centre de
détention de 400 places à fleur Mogis
que j'ai inauguré avec le président
Houlier la semaine
dernière j'inaugurerai demain la prison
de trois Lavau qui comptera près de 500
places d'ici la fin de l'année j'aurai
le plaisir d'inaugurer deux autres
établissements à osni et à ma en
2024 le programme de construction se
poursuivra avec la même intensité et
concernera se chantiers quatre nouveaux
établissements seront livrés Toulon
noisilgr Colmar Nim trois sites
pénitentiaes finaliseront leur première
phase de travaux Bordeaux
Gradignan Baster et bemao en
2024 c'est 308 millions d'euros qui
seront budgetés pour la réalisation du
programme de construction pénitentiaire
à ce jour ce sont près de 2 milliards
d'euros qui ont été investis dans ce
plan de construction par rapport à un
coût estimatif de 5 milliards d'euros au
total enfin concernant la
réhabilitation d'établissement existant
les opérations courantes de maintenance
représentent 130 millions d'euros en
2024 nous maintenons ce très haut niveau
d'investissement annuel qui représente
le double le double de celui investi
lors du quinquena du président
Hollande depuis près de 6 ans et
concernant freine et poissie de 2
millionson d'euros seront en particulier
consacrés aux études de leur
réhabilitation madame madame la
rapporteur pour avis madame tanzili mais
je sais qu'elle est souffrante et
qu'elle est remplacée peut pas évoquer
l'immobilier pénitentiaire sans évoquer
l'immobilier judiciaire pour lequel je
souhaite en poursuivre évidemment la
modernisation l'agrandissement afin
notamment de permettre l'accueil des
renforts humains que j'ai
au début de mon propos au total 362
millions d'euros seront consacrés en
2024 à l'immobilier judiciaire
propriétaire par rapport à
269 millions d'euros en 2023 c'est une
hausse vous avez déjà fait le calcul de
près de 35 % en une année ces crédits
permettront de poursuivre notamment les
20 principaux chantiers suivants trois
nouveaux palais de justice à Lille
Saint-Benoît à la Réunion Saint-Laurent
du Maroni en Guyane 15 restructurations
extension de palais qui existe déjà
haras Bayonne Bourges bourgouinjalieu
Chaumont Carcasson é fort defance Macon
Nancy Nant nanter Paris Cité Versailles
et Vienne deux réhabilitation de
bâtiments tiers pour construire des
annexes au palais justice Agor et
valencienne mesdames et messieurs pour
finir je souhaite mettre en lumière
certaines enveloppes qui me tiennent à
cœur car elles ont pour vocation de
moderniser et d'améliorer concrètement
le fonctionnement du service public de
la justice ainsi que le bien-être de ses
agents tout d'abord les crédits
d'investissement informatique dont les
techniques d'enquête numérique
judiciaire sont porté à 209 millions
soit une hausse de 7,2
pour en une année ces crédits vont
permettre en particulier de poursuivre
le second plan de transformation
numérique du
ministère véritable plan de numérisation
de la justice en France et ce plan va
s'articuler autour de trois projets
principaux un plan de soutien au profit
des agents du ministère sur le terrain
en particulier au sein des
juridiction cela passe par le
recrutement de 100 techniciens
informatiques de proximité en 2023 dont
80 mesdames et messieurs ont d'ors et
déjà été recrutés puis 100 autres
techniciens supplémentaires seront
recrutés en
2024 ça passe également par la
modernisation des logiciels
métiers ça passe également
par cet objectif que nous maintenons de
100 % de numérisation d'ici la fin du
quinquena ce sujet avance concrètement
je voudrais vous donner un seul exemple
à mon arrivée la procédure pénale
numérique était dans un état
embryonnaire il y avait environ 500
procédures transmise de manière
dématérialisée des enquêteurs vers le
tribunau par mois et aujourd'hui nous en
somme à près de
150000 c'est-à-dire une multiplication
de plus de par plus de de
300 la direction programme
euh direction programme commun PPN
intérieur justice a été créé en juin et
va permettre d'accélérer de manière
décisive cette progression pour conduire
la démarche zéro papier à son terme
jusqu'à 2027 j'ai souhaité qu'un
directeur de projet dédié soit désigné
au sein du Secrétariat général du
ministère il prendra ses fonctions début
2024 l'enveloppe de crédit consacré aux
dépenses des frais de justice sera porté
à 6 174 millions en 2024 pour renforcer
bien sûr les moyens d'enquête et
d'expertise de la justice soit une
hausse mesdames et messieurs les députés
de 14 millions d'euros par rapport à
2023 par rapport à 2017 où le budget
consacré était de
496 millions d'euros ça représente un
effort de 36 % de plus ce nouvel effort
contribuera notamment à faciliter le
déstockage des affaires les crédits
d'accès au droit et à la justice
s'élèveront à 734 millions d'euros en
2024 hausse de 3 % par rapport à
2023 qui
s'établissait à
714 millions plus
spécifiquement dans cette enveloppe les
crédit dédiés à l'aide
juridictionnelle continueront de croître
en 2024 pour atteindre 657 millions
d'euros soit 16 millions de plus en une
année parallèlement l'aide aux victimes
est porté 47 millions en 2024 soit une
hausse de 2 million d'euros par rapport
à 2023 et enfin enfin concernant
l'action sociale offerte par le
ministère à ses
agents essentiel bien sûr pour assurer
leur soutien et contribuer à
l'attractivité de notre institution ce
sont 33 millions d'euros qui seront
mobilisés soit 13 % de plus qu'en 2023
ce budget va permettre notamment d'agir
en faveur de la politique d'aide aux
familles de réduire les restes à charge
en terme de service de restauration de
faciliter l'accès au logement et à la
propriété pour les agents notamment via
un ajustement du prêt bonifié immobilier
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
suis à présent à votre disposition pour
répondre à toute des questions que vous
voudrez bien me
poser merci Monsieur le Ministre al on
va d'abord donner la parole à nos
rapporteur je rappelle que suppl la
rapporteur madame Sarah tanzili
rapporteur pour les avis de la justice
et l'accès au droit monsieur le
rapporteur Jean Terlier vous avez la
parole pour commencer avant votre second
rapporteur merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je voudrais avant de commencer mon
propos évidemment remercier et féliciter
saranzili pour l'excellence de de son
travail et je la suppl avec grand
plaisir le budget qui vous a présenté
cette année et la traduction financière
concrète de l'ambition de donner à notre
justice les moyens nécessaires à
l'accomplissement de sa mission telle
qu'elle s'est manifestée à l'occasion
des états généraux de la justice et la
loi d'orientation et de
programmation ce budget renforce
fortement la hausse des crédits déjà
entamé l'an dernier au bénéfice de
plusieurs objectifs prioritaires réduire
les délais d'audiosement et les stocks
d'affaires en attente améliorer les
conditions de travail des agents de
l'institution judiciaire et enfin mieux
accompagner les justiciables pour cela
ce budget prévoit d'une part
l'augmentation des effectifs
prioritairement au sein des juridictions
d'autre part des revalorisations
salariales pour les
agents enfin une hausse des crédits pour
l'accès au droits et l'aide aux victimes
et ainsi que l'augmentation des crédits
dédiés à l'immobilier judiciaire et à la
transformation numérique s'agissant de
la justice judiciaire la hausse du
budget s'élève à pas moins de 9 5 % des
crédits de paiement afin de recruter
près de 1300 personnels au total dans
l'année à venir dans le détail il s'agit
entre autre de plus de 300 magistrats
340 greffiers 513 personnels
d'encadrement pour former de véritables
équipes autour du magistrat ces
recrutements s'inscrivent dans
l'objectif réaffirmé ici de recruter
plus de 1500 magistrats et 1800
greffiers supplémentaire d'ici 2027 en
outre les mesures de relevalisation
salariale débuté en 2023 connaîtront
leur première année pleine en
2024 pour ce qui est de l'accès au
droits et à l'aide aux victimes les
crédits augmentent de 2,8 % par rapport
à l'année dernière avec un effort
conséquent sur l'accès au droit et le
réseau judiciaire de proximité qui
bénéficie pour sa part d'une hausse de
près de 10 %. l'objectif est d'offrir un
maillage territorial plus fin en créant
notamment de nouvelles permanence pour
les maisons de justice et d'accès au
droit l'aide aux victimes est également
renforcée afin de soutenir le réseau
d'associations local qui accompagne
juridiquement socialement
psychologiquement les victimes la
thématique de la vie budgétaire porté
par notre collègue Sarah tanzili porte
sur l'immobilier judiciaire et la
numérisation de l'institution
judiciaire ce thème harid au premier
abord est en réalité essentiel afin
d'assurer que la justice bénéficie à
plein des orientations définies pour les
années à venir il serait en effet
regrettable de recruter aussi
massivement que nous le faisons pour que
les personnels de disposeent ni des
outils ni des locaux adaptés à
l'accomplissement de leur mission c'est
pourquoi les moyens ne manquent pas en
la matière avec une augmentation de
crédit de paiement de près de 35 %
dévolue à l'immobilier judiciaire
l'immobilier judiciaire est soumis à des
contraintes d'ordre symbolique de volume
et sécuritaire les acteurs de la justice
sont légitimement attachés à ce que nos
tribunaux soit s'installer au cœur de la
cité et incarne solennité et incarne la
solennité de leur mission toutefois cela
peut entraîner des tensions entre gestes
architectural et besoins des personnels
les conditions de travail doivent donc
impérativement être prises en compte
lors de la mise en chantier un autre
défi est celui de l'arrivée de nouvelles
recrues qui aura un fort impact sur les
besoins en surface disponibles au sein
des juridictions déjà exang pour
certaines plusieurs leviers sont
utilisés la densification des espaces
existants le partage des de bureau ou
encore la réserve foncière ou
immobilière malgré cela la prise à bail
sont les prises à bail sont inévitables
de manière temporaire afin de pouvoir
trouver de la place à chacun la
rapporteur tanzili soulligne la
nécessité de prendre en compte le
principe de mutualité des services
publics afin de ne pas s'engager dans
des opérations immobilières majeures qui
deviendrai un fardeau sur le très long
terme car inadapté au changement de la
justice sur les prochaines
décennies la gouvernance de l'immobilier
judiciaire est de plus en plus complexe
et peu lisible pour les acteurs de
terrain les premiers pas vers une
déconcentration de la décision au niveau
local sont donc les bienvenus enfin les
enjeux de sécurité au sein des
juridictions ont entraîné le
renforcement des contrôles la
multiplication des badgets d'accès et la
séparation stricte entre locaux
professionnels et lieux accessibles au
public ce qui a pu créer une forme de
frustration chez les auxiliaires de
justice notamment les avocats qui ont
parfois du mal à accéder au bureau de
leurs
interlocuteurs les besoins des
justiciable en particulier des victimes
doivent également être pris en compte
dans la gestion de l'immobilier
judiciaire la fédération France victime
a regretté notamment que les bureaux d'
aux victimes ne disposent pas tous de
locaux dans chaque juridiction et que
victimes et accusés puissent souvent se
croiser dans les espaces communs la
rapporteur souhaite enfin alerter sur le
besoin d'une salle dite des grands
procès puisque celle construite à
l'occasion du procès des attentats du 13
novembre ne pourra pas être conservée
plus d'une année les procès en appel des
attentats et le contentieux de masse qui
risque de seier multiplier à l'avenir
renforce ce besoin une grande salle
d'audience qui a également une portée
symbolique forte doit donc être
pérennisée s'agissant de la
numérosisation de la justice il convient
de souligner que le premier plan pardon
de transformation numérique a porté ses
fruits en accordant au personnel des
outils physiques adapté à leurs besoins
l'effort du second plan de
transformation portera principalement
sur le développement et le renforcement
des applicatifs métier en la matière
n'ayons pas peur des mots il existe une
vraie souffrance des personnels face à
des Judici
souvent peu fiable sousdimensionné et
parfois peu ergonomique il est urgent
donc d'assurer au professionnels de
bonnes conditions de travail c'est
également une question de bonne gestion
des deners publics il serait dommageable
de recruter des personnels pour qu'il
dépendent pour qu'il dépense pardon leur
énergie et leur temps de travail à
trouver des solutions pour contourner
des outils numériques inadaptés il
pourrait donc être utile à l'avenir de
s'appliquer de s'appuyer sur des
applicatifs peut-être moins ambitieux
mais plus fiables dans leur utilisation
en outre une consultation approfondie
des utilisateurs finaux de ces logiciels
serait bénéfique durant leur conception
et tout au long de leur
utilisation la rapporteur salue par
ailleurs l'internalisation partielle des
capacités numériques avec des
recrutements de personnel technique pour
accompagner les juridictions dans le
déploiement de l'entretien de nouveaux
outils je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur Éric pouliia pour
la
mission administration pénitentiaire et
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues rapporteur
chers collègues alors je ne vais pas
revenir sur l'ensemble toute l'évolution
globale des moyens d'évolu à
l'administration pénitentiaire et à la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
monsieur le le garde des saut les a
présenté et il est difficile selon moi
de contester les efforts qui sont
consentis de manière pérenne en faveur
de ces deux
administrations s'agissant des des
crédits de l'administration p cière je
voudrais toutefois attirer votre
attention sur deux sujets il s'agit
d'une part de la situation des
surveillants depuis 2017 en parallèle
des avancées budgétaires nous avons
œuvré à la revalorisation en profondeur
du statut et du métier de surveillant
pénitentiaire rappelons par exemple la
signature en 2021 par le Garde des saau
de la charte du surveillant
acteur loin du modèle de porte-clé qui a
trop longtemps prévalu nous avons ainsi
si diversifier les missions du
surveillant pour reconnaître
concrètement son rôle d'acteur
incontournable d'une détention
sécurisé plusieurs efforts indemnitaires
ont également été réalisés avec
l'augmentation progressive de la
rémunération des jeunes agents débutants
dans la
profession et je me réjouis de voir
cette année le projet de loi de finance
traduire une nouvelle étape de cette
revalorisation en 2024 les surveillants
connaîtront une réforme majeure avec
leur passage de la catégorie C à la
catégorie B il s'agit là d'une réforme
historique dont nous devons saluer
l'importance et la
pertinence en second lieu je voudrais
profiter de cette discussion budgétaire
pour rappeler vous l'avez fait monsieur
le garde des saau mais je voudrais aussi
en parler l'avancement du plan 15000 est
dissipé les doutes que certains font
naître parfois à tort l'année 2023 a été
une année tournant pour la réalisation
de la de ce plan sur les 51 établ
programmé 11 ont été ouverts cette année
rien qu'en ce mois d'octobre ce sont
1000 places netes qui sont sorties de
terre dans l'histoire de notre
administration pénitentiaire c'est tout
simplement le mois où le plus de places
de prison ont été
créées ces livraisons nous permettront
d'atteindre à la fin de l'année le
premier tiers du plan
15000 ce résultat me paraît plus
qu'honorable d'autant plus qu'il aurait
été il aura été atteint pardonnez-moi
malgré la crise covid malgré les
difficultés du secteur de la
construction et malgré les réticences
locales encouragées par certains élus
locaux parfois les premiers à dénoncer
le laxisme de la
justice mais le chemin ne s'arrête pas
là 36 opérations sont encore prévues
dans le cadre de ce plan 14 sont en
cours 5 sont entrés en phase d'étude de
conception quatre sont actuellement
soumises aux appels d'offre et en vue du
choix du constructeur et 13 sont au
stade d'étude préalable normalement à la
fin de l'année prochaine près de la
moitié des établissements auront été
livré ce dont nous pouvons nous réjouir
car je tiens à le rappeler qu'au-delà du
débat sur l'accroissement de nos
capacités d'emprisonnement sur lequel
nos positions peuvent diverger nous
devons tous nous retrouver sur une
réalité et nous en avons déjà parlé
l'année dernière d'ailleurs ces
constructions de nouvelles préson
permettront d'améliorer les conditions
de détention des personnes incarcérées
et les conditions de travail des
personnels pénitentia ce double objectif
et je crois une boussole que nous ne
devons jamais perdre de vue c'est
d'ailleurs une boussole qui guide une
autre des dépenses qui ont été largement
revalorisé au fil des différentes lois
de finance le montant consacré à la
maintenance et à la rénovation des
établissements
existant l'entretien du parc
pénitentiaire représente en effet un
défi logistique et budgétaire qui a été
sous-évalué par les majorités
précédentes et que nous nous nous sommes
appliqués à relever avec succès je crois
puisque ces budgets ont été doublés et
permettent aujourd'hui de conduire
d'importants chantiers
d'entretien voire de réhabilitation
complète lorsque cela s'avère nécessaire
comme ce sera le cas par exemple à
freine dans les prochaines
années j'en viiens à présent à la
seconde partie de mon rapport que j'ai
choisi cette année de consacrer à la
santé mentale des personnes
détenues depuis plusieurs années déjà
les auditions déplacements et autres
contacts que j'ai pu avoir avec le monde
panitentière m'ont conduit à constater
que l'état de santé mental et les
modalités de prise en charge
psychiatrique des personnes détenues
constituaient un sujet de préoccupation
pour les acteurs de
terrain publié en début d'année une
étude épidémiologique nationale sur la
santé mentale en sortie de prison est
venu confirmer ses constats
empiriques les de 2 tiers des hommes
détenus en maison d'arrêt et les tr/4
des femmes présentent à la sortie de
prison un trouble
psychiatrique ou une addiction liée à
une
substance la prévalence des troubles
psychiatriques est ainsi bien plus
importante que dans la population
générale c'est je crois un constat qui
doit nous faire
réfléchir l'année 2024 devant marquer le
lancement de la deuxème phase de
construction des unités hospitalière
spécialement aménagé appelé UHSA il m'a
donc semblé pertinent de faire le point
sur les prise en charge proposé pour les
personnes détenues bien sûr il s'agit là
d'un sujet très vaste qui ne peut être
entièrement traité dans une moitié de
rapport budgétaire pour
avis mais je pense que ce point d'étape
sera utile pour permettre à notre
commission de se pencher sur le
sujet d'ailleurs dès 2017 sous
l'impulsion de la présidente ybron pivé
de notre collègue Stéphane Mazard la
commission des lois avait constitué un
groupe de travail sur la prise en charge
des détenus souffrant de trouble
psychiatriques et formulé plusieurs
recommandations
il me semble que ce sujet mérite que
nous continuions d'y être
particulièrement attentif et je voudrais
profiter de votre présence parmi nous
monsieur le ministre pour vous
interroger sur deux points
particuliers au cours de mes
déplacements j'ai à plusieurs reprises
été alerté sur les difficultés rencontré
pardonnez-moi en matière d'extraction
sanitaire celles-ci sont de deux ordres
d'une part s'agissant des extractions
pour se rendre à un rendez-vous médical
les équipes semblent souvent déborder et
ne peuvent pas réaliser toutes les ex
action conduisant à l'annulation de
nombreux rendez-vous ce qui nuit au
suivi sanitaire et psychiatrique d'autre
part concernant plus spécifiquement les
UHSA ce sont les équipes pénitentiaires
de l'UHSA qui sont chargés d'aller
chercher les détenus devant être
hospitalisés or les distances sont
parfois longues entre l'établissement et
l'hôpital de rattachement ce qui conduit
parfois à limiter les possibilité
d'extraction et nuit à la prise en
charge des détenus incarcérés dans les
établissements les plus éloignés
raphiquement de
l'UHSA pouvez-vous nous préciser ce qui
est fait pour répondre à ces
difficultés je ne serai pas plus long et
je m'entiendrai à ce sujet des Ussa le
lancement de la seconde tranche
longtemps attendu doit enfin être
enclenché l'année prochaine même si cela
ne révèle pas entièrement
l'administration pénitentiaire puisqu'il
s'agit de structure hospitalière
pouvez-vous nous préciser ce qui sera
fait en 2024 dans ce domaine je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
alors avant de passer la parole aux
orateurs des groupes moi j'ai trois
questions monsieur le ministre vous avez
rappelé que nous avons inauguré le
centre l'aile du centre pénitentiaire de
fleur merochis qui correspondait à la
milliè place net de prison que vous
aviez ouverte cette année vous avez
annoncé deux ouvertures prochaines à
venir donc je voudrais que vous nous
disiez le nombre de places netes qui
seront ouverte pour la seule année 2023
en comparaison au PL 15000 que vous avez
annoncé ce que j'aimerais aussi que vous
nous disiez c'est là où vous avez des
discussions avec les collectivités qui
ne permettent pas l'ouverture de ces de
ces prisons puisque ces collectivités
aujourd'hui retardent empêche ou bloque
l'exécution du plan 15000 que nous
souhaitons tous et donc j'aimerais que
vous puissiez nous faire connaître
l'identité de ces collectivités ensuite
vous avez évoqué un accord avec les
greffiers dont vous avez parlé des
revalorisation des revalorisations qui
concernent les magistrats à hauteur de
1000 € par mois les agents
pénitentiaires avec une remontée dans un
la grille indiciaire de la catégorie C à
la catégorie B et donc avec les
greffiers pour un premier accord à
hauteur de 15 millions d'euros vous avez
parlé d'une réforme approfondie je
voudrais savoir si vous avez des
éléments supplémentaires à nous
communiquer sur ces aspectsl en dehors
de l'accord que vous avez conclu le le
12 septembre dernier enfin nous avons
dans le cadre du suivi budgétaire une
attention particulière pour
l'accélération des procédures vous
l'avais dit l'accélération des
procédures civiles l'accélération des
procédures pénales qui font l'objet
aujourd'hui de travaux de la part de
votre ministère c'est sur les procédures
civiles que je voudrais avoir une
réponse de votre part sur la question de
la formation des les magistrats
notamment aux deux procédures nouvelles
que vous avez adopté par voie
règlementaire cet été des procédures
civiles qui concerne la césure et donc
la capacité de juger d'abord au fond
avant de renvoyer à l'indemnisation des
victimes et la procédure de l'amiable et
si les magistrats bénéficient de façon
continue ou de façon initiale à une
formation particulière à ces deux
nouvelles procédures de façon à assurer
leur succès je vous remercie ce sont les
questions monsieur président non ce sont
le trois je vous je vous les donne
d'ailleurs et je vais donner la parole à
différents orateurs madame Caroline Abad
pour le groupe Renaissance merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président messieurs
les les rapporteurs monsieur le ministre
chers collègues le budget de la justice
pour 2024 dans la continuité des années
précédentes est marqué par une hausse
cette fois-ci vraiment massive de 5,3 %
par rapport à à 2023 cette trajectoire
historique répond à la nécessité de
moderniser notre service public de la
justice sur le plan numérique d'abord
l'investissement continuera de
progresser pour rendre la justice plus
accessible plus rapide plus efficace
plus transparente avec un horizon zéro
papier à à
2027 ensuite sur le plan immobilier avec
de nombreux chantiers monsieur le
ministre vous avez même rappelé que le
tribunal de Vienne était lui-même
concerné par ce plan de rénovation et je
peux vous le certifier il y en avait
vraiment besoin on ne pouvait plus
pousser les murs au tribunal de Vienne
sur le plan humain nous lui donnons
enfin les moyens de recruter massivement
des magistrats des greffiers des
juristes assist des surveillants
pénitentiaes associé à de fortes
revalorisations salarial et catégorial
que vous avez d'ailleurs évoqué nous
connaissons votre volonté tenace pour
reconnaître à sa juste valeur notamment
la mission centrale des greffiers et on
aurait vraiment voulu savoir où en
étaient vos négociations avec eux parce
que nous savons que vous avez beaucoup
discuté avec eux en en septembre et ils
sont venus nombreux dans nos permanences
sur chacun de nos
territoires quant à la justice pénale
des mineurs
le bilan est déjà plus que positif pour
rappel les délais de jugement sont
désormais de 8 mois l'indemnisation des
victimes intervient au moins en moins de
3 mois alors qu'il fallait attendre
auparavant 18 mois nous poursuivons nos
efforts avec 8 million d'euros
supplémentaires qui alimenteront ce
programme pour notamment mettre en œuvre
trois plans d'action structurant sur le
milieu ouvert j'aurais voulu que vous n
précisiez les contours et les finalités
de ces trois plans d'action si c'était
possible nous avons également avec ce
budget un souci constant des victimes 2
millions supplémentaires pour le budget
d'aide aux victimes d'infraction pénale
nous Aion savoir nous aimerions savoir
également où en sont comment les pôles
spécialisés en en matière de lutte
contre les violences intrafamiliales que
nous avons créé dans la l'obg vont être
déployés dans nos
juridiction sur le pénitentiaire nous
nous réjouissons bien sûr de ces moyens
renforcés afin de poursuivre le plan
15000 qui constitue l'une des solutions
indispensables pour réduire la la
surpopulation carcérale alors vous savez
bien sûr monsieur le ministre que
personnellement
je crois que en complément il faudra
aussi planifier durablement la réduction
de la surpopulation carcérale j'ai noté
comme monsieur le Président des
réticences des élus locaux
d'île-de-fance notamment où les besoins
sont pourtant très importants comme un
oiseau dans le Val de Marne la région a
tenté de faire obstruction à la
construction de place de prison je pense
que ça peut condamner d'avance les 3000
places supplémentaires qui étaient voulu
par certains comment faites-vous face à
ces obstacles est-ce que cela met en
retard la livraison des établissements
péniten
grâce à à ce budget pénitentiaire grâce
à ce budget les métiers pénitentiaires
seront également revalorisés et je pense
au directeurs de service d'insertion et
de probation que nous avions pas oublié
dans la lobg savoir si vous pouviez nous
en dire quelques mots
également et pour avoir toujours cet
objectif de réinertion en tête je
voulais parler des 10 structures de
contrôle judiciaire sous placacement
probatoire les cjpp que nous continuons
de financer à hauteur de 2,5 million
d'euros pour 165 places qui lutent
efficacement contre les violences conj
conjugales il existe en parallèle 30
centres de prise en charge d'auteur de
violence conjugal dont j'avais moi-même
souhaité la création lors du Grenel des
violences conjugales ces deux structures
ont pour point commun des taux de
récidive très faibles les cjpp dépendent
de votre ministère les CPA du ministère
de l'Égalité hommes-femm je voulais
savoir comment nous pouvons articuler
ces deux dispositifs et je pe cette
question à dessin et j'en termine là
monsieur le Président ma conviction est
qu'il faudrait probablement les
rassembler pour permettre un financement
péren à ocpca merci Monsieur Philippe
Schrek pour le groupe rassemblement
national merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre messieurs les
rapporteurs nous sommes donc réuni pour
évoquer un budget nous l'avons dit sans
surprise puisque prolongeant la
discussion et le vote de la loi de
programmation de la justice où presque
tout a été évoqué concernant la
trajectoire budgétaire de la justice et
c'est vrai qu'il aurait été pour le
moins étonnant que le budget diffère de
ce qui a été voté il y a quelques
semaines et l'exercice peut paraître
même superficiel voir un petit peu vain
puisque nous savons comment tout ça va
se terminer en séance avec le
déclenchement de l'article
493 quoi qu'il en soit la hausse des
crédits de la justice c'est toujours une
bonne chose tant-il est vrai et nous le
savons certains d'entre nous pour
l'avoir vécu que nous partons de très
loin euh mais en 2023 il faut non plus
pas trop euh fortement se glorifier
d'une hausse des budgets à hauteur de
5,3 % l'année une hausse de 5,3 % annuel
le montant de l'inflation 2023 est de
5,8 % celui prévu en 2024 sera au
minimum de 3,3 % sûrement plus par
rapport à ces réalités macro-économiques
le budget de la justice que nous savons
sensible à hausse des prix notamment en
son volet immobilier est un budget qui
court après l'inflation vous l'avez dit
monsieur monsie le ministre cette
progression pour une grande part est
fléchée par la hausse des traitements
des magistrats afin de les aligner sur
celui des juges administratifs et ainsi
convaincre ces derniers de rejoindre la
justice judiciaire qui peinene à
recruter si l'idée est acceptable et et
voire bonne il n'est pas certain qu'elle
soit couronnée de succès et on dit
beaucoup sur les difficultés
d'attractivité des métiers de la justice
difficultés qui ont été appréendé dans
le cadre des sous-exécutions budgétaires
constatées au titre de l'année 2022 et
puis cette hosse ne représente pas en
elle-même une augmentation des moyens
donnés à la justice car mieux payé éant
mieux pour eux le rendement quantitatif
et qualitatif des magistrats ne va pas
pour autant croître et les stocks vont
demeurer les greffiers acteurs
indispensables de la coproduction
judiciaire sont laissés sur le bord de
la route avec leur faible rémunération
près de 100 millions lissés sur l'année
pour l'augmentation des traitements des
juges ne9 fois moins pour les greffiers
à ce rythme il sera difficile
d'atteindre les 1800 nouveaux postes de
greffe imaginé par la loi de
programmation orors à quoi serviront
1500 joues supplémentaires s'ils ne sont
pas accompagnés de 1800 greffiers
supplémentaires bien entendu nous
approuvons la poursuite du plan 15 18000
places de prison nette il en va des
conditions de détention digne d'adapter
l'outil pénitentiaire à la progression
des chiffres de la délinquence et puis
la réalisation de ce plan est aussi un
moyen concret d'échapper à la régulation
carcérale qui pour nous une lubie de
ceux qui refusent de voir l'état du pays
et veulent institutionnaliser les
opérations portes ouvertes de nos
prisons cependant ce plan est difficile
il aurait dû être achevé en 2022 il est
dur à mis en œuvre à à être mis en œuvre
et les places inaugurées récemment
résultent parfois de projets lancés
avant ce plan euh ce plan sera efficient
par ailleurs s'il est accompagné de
recrutement massif au sein de
l'administration pénitentiaire qu'elle
aussi souffre d'un déficit
d'attractivité en ce sens nous serons
attentifs au sort qui sera réservé aux
amendements visant à améliorer la
situation indiciaire des agents ainsi
que ce permettant de renforcer la
sécurité active et passive des prisons
enfin nous considérons que l'AC l'accès
au droit notamment la judiciaire ne
progresse pas suffisamment elle
progresse 2 et demi % soit deux fois
moins que le budget général de la
justice nous pouvons donc à ce niveau
parler de recul nous considérons que la
justice demeurera encore dans le casadre
de l'exercice à venir celle de la
lenteur et de l'engorgement embolisation
des parquets surcharge des SPIP dès là
normalement long en est en appel CPH
encore traumatisé par les faits de
réforme précédentes la liste n'est
malheureusement pas exhaustive je vous
remercie merci peut-être une observation
sur le les missions que nous examinons
ici d'abord elles ont toutes été examiné
et voté l'année dernière lors de lexamen
du projet de loi de finance donc je
tiens qu'à vous à ce que ce soit le cas
ensuite dans le cadre de de de
l'hémicycle et ensuite pour la question
des des amendements je je CIS pas que 20
parce que il y a 100 amendements ce qui
est un record absolu sur les mission de
justice qu'ils émanent de différents
groupes et donc si c'était 20 je pense
qu'il y en aurait pas autant à notre
examen Monsieur Jean-François coulom
pour le groupe la France insoumise merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs
collègues nous examinons aujourd'hui le
budget alloué à la justice pour l'année
à venir pour cela il convient de
rappeler le contexte dans lequel est
rendue la justice actuellement en France
et de saisir les enjeux d'un tel budget
face au déficit humain matériel et
financiers dont souffre votre ministère
chaque programme du budget de la justice
dont vous êtes chargé répond chaque
année à la même logique une politique
obsédée par le tout sécuritaire et le
tout carcéral ainsi vous vous félicitez
d'une hausse dans votre budget de 503
millions d'euros mais c'est sans compter
une inflation record sur les coûts
portant cette haosse en réalité à 220
millions d'euros une augmentation
dérisoire est concentrée dans
l'ouverture de nouveaux établissements
pénitentiaires l'hypertrophie d'une
cours d'assistant autour du magistrat
l'élargissement de techniqu d'enquête
toujours plus intrusive pour des
échelles de peine toujours plus basses
c'est donc une politique répressive que
vous déployez cette année encore prenons
la peine d'analyser les programmes de
votre budget pour la justice judiciaire
vous privilégiez comme toujours la
justice pénale et la justice civile avec
238 millions d'euros supplémentaires
pour la première vous créez
principalement des postes d'assistants
plutôt que des postes de magistrats ou
de greffiers qui sont pourtant
indispensables à la réduction des délais
de traitement des instances vous
développez des procédures à l'amiables
qui conduisent à une déjudiciarisation
du contentieux civil et procéder à une
reffonte de la justice commerciale qui
nourrira immanquablement les conflits
d'intérêts quant à l'administration
pénitentiaire encore une année où il
s'agit du budget le plus élevé au sein
de la mission que nous examinons et qui
est SEP fois supérieur à celui pour
l'accès au droits et et à la justice
pour ne citer qu'un exemple vous
projetez dans ce budget la livraison de
quatre établissements pénitentiaires
pour 2024 équivalent à 570 places de
prison mais pourquoi persistez-vous avec
une telle politique carcérale qui ne
répond qu'à votre fantasme d'enfermer
toujours plus et toujours plus longtemps
une once de bon sens et d'honnêteté
intellectuelle devrait suffire à vous
faire admettre que davantage de places
de prison ne mène qu'à une chose les
remplir sans EMB baisser le taux de
surpopulation qui est un record en
Europe comme cela a été pointé par le
CEDH alors comment expliquer cette
obsession monsieur le ministre si ce
n'est par une politique d'idéologie
sécuritaire dont le but ultime n'est pas
de remédier à cette surpopulation
mortifère dont vous ne semblez que pour
vous émouvoir mais simplement de mener à
bien un projet de société du tout
répressif dans son dernier rapport
d'activité la Contrôleur général des
lieux de privation de liberté dresse un
constat sans équivoque sur la nécessité
d'un mécanisme de régulation carcérale
constat que partage notre groupe groupe
la France insoumise les solutions ne
manquent pas pour cela en revanche ce
qui manque c'est d'une volonté politique
de votre volonté politique concernant la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse à
l'image de l'administration
pénitentiaire une partie du budget est
orientée vers la réalisation
d'opérations immobilières d'ampleur avec
la construction de centre éducatif
fermés ce recours au CF n'est qu'une
preuve de plus de votre incapacité à
vous appuyer sur une politique
d'accompagnement plutôt que sur la
répression et l'enfermement des mineurs
la fermeture de ces centres serait un
moyen de récupérer une partie desé
coûtes de fonctionnement et de
construction pour d'autres mesures
alternatives et
préventives le budget pour l'accès au
droit et à la justice n'est pas plus
glorieux puisque votre augmentation est
dérisoire et ne permet pas la
valorisation de la durédictionnel ni de
l'aide aux victimes d'infraction pénal
il est urgent de mettre fin à cette
précarisation de notre service public de
la justice garante principale de nos
droits et libertés il faut des moyens
financiers humains conséquents qui
doivent conduire notamment au
recrutement massif de nouveaux
fonctionnaires mais aussi un changement
de paradigme en matière d'échelle des
peines et de sens de la peine votre
politique du tout sécuritaire et de
privation de liberté comme principe ne
doivent plus guider les politiques
publiques de la justice merci Monsieur
Xavier Breton pour le boupl
républicain mer si Monsieur le le
président monsieur le garde des saau
monsieur les les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues on est un peu face à un budget
en trompleœuil c'està-dire ça dépend de
quel dans quel angle nous nous plaçons
monsieur le ministre vous êtes placé
passé dans dans dans dans l'angle de
celui qui construit le budget qui le
présente effectivement avec la
perspective qui lui convient mais quand
on le regarde d'un autre angle et c'est
notre notre cas on a des interrogations
tout d'abord pour les montants il y a
effectivement cette progression de 5 %
en crédit de paiement sur l'année mais
qui correspond en fait au au taux de
l'inflation ce qui veut dire que en
Euroc constant la hausse est relative et
est on a plus une stagnation cette
ensuite sur la répartition des efforts
il faut donner acte effectivement aux
créations d'emplois qui sont faites 1300
dans dans les services judiciaires 450
dans l'administration pénitentiaire bon
il faudra voir effectivement quel statut
on sait emplois notamment si on a
beaucoup de de contractuels ou ou
d'assistants ou alors si c'est vraiment
des des postes vraiment de titulaires
mais dont acte en tout cas pour ces
créations d'emploi par contre pour les
investissements immobiliers là il y a
quand même beaucoup d'interrogation le
bilan effectivement nettement
insuffisant et contrairement à ce que
disait notre collègue rapporteur on a
aujourd'hui des crédits d'investissement
immobilier qui vont être de 518 millions
d'euros pour 2024 ce qui va représenter
une baisse de 132 millions par rapport à
la loi de finance initiale de l'année
dernière euh on nous avions fait
inscrire lors de de la l'examen de la
loi euh d'orientation de programmation
3000 places de prison supplémentaires ce
qui fait d'ailleurs on ne doit plus
parler du plan 15000 mais bien du plan
18000 euh cependant on voit bien que
au-delà des des annonces titriantes qui
peuvent être faites ça va pas être suivi
des faits en 2017 Emmanuel Macron alors
candidat avait promis avait s'était
engagé à construire 15000 nouvelles plac
sur le mandat l'objectif a été ramené à
7000 puis à 4500 2022 dans les fêtes
depuis 2017 seul 2500 places
supplémentaires ont été construites en
France on le voit bien que on est loin
effectivement des objectifs ce qui pose
notamment le problème de la
surpopulation carcérale rappelons que
fin en fin d'année 2022 euh nous avons
atteint le niveau inégalé de 73000
détenus dans notre pays et puis derrière
ces ces ces chiffres il y a
effectivement des secteurs qui restent
en avec des beaucoup d'interrogations
dans ce budget de la justice ou avec des
secteurs en souffrance je pense à l'aide
juridictionnelle la Cour des comptes
vient de s'alarmer du manque
d'encadrement de ce dispositif et et
appelle effectivement à ce qui est un
pilotage vraiment de cette aide
jurictionnelle qui soit faite l'aide aux
victimes qui est toujours aussi indiqué
en disant il y a le travail formidable
des associations mais on se rend compte
que la hausse est inférieure à
l'inflation c'est 4 % seulement des
crédits supplémentaires qui seront pour
les associations des de victimes alors
même qu'elles font un travail
remarquable ce sont les centreséducatifs
fermés euh là aussi la Cour des comptes
vient d'appeler à ce qu'il y ait une
véritable évaluation qui soit faite de
ces centres éducatifs fermés et puis il
y a toute la question de l'informatique
où on sait que dans nos tribunaux et
bien il y a des défaillances et des
dysfonctionnements très importants des
systèmes informatiques qui empêchent un
bon traitement des affaires et puis je
finirai par la question des greffes il y
a le mouvement historique qu'on connaît
qui qui s'est effectivement développé
dans tous les tribunaux sur le
territoire suite à des promesses qui ne
sont pas tenues il y a des négociations
mais Monsieur le gardesso les chiffres
que vous annoncez moi en tout cas c'est
pas ceux que j'entends quand vous
indiquer des des hausses de rémunération
de 300 € dans les faet ça se limite
plutôt autour de 100 € mensuel vous
indiquez des revalorisations dans en
catégorie A pour 3200 sur 11000 greffi
comment vont-ils être choisis sur quel
critère tout ça ça reste effectivement
avec beaucoup de points d'interrogation
on sait l'importance du GREF d'un GREF
compétent et formé dans l'organisation
judiciaire je crois que ça serait
important qu'on leur adresse un signal
et bien qu'ils ont toutes leur place
pour le bon fonctionnement de notre
institution judiciaire je vous remercie
monsieuran balanan pour le groupe
démocrate merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre monsieurs mesdames
messieurs les députés mes chers
collègues euh la vérité et la justice
sont souveraines car elle seule assure
la grandeur des nations alors ces mots
d'émilzola concentrent à eux seul
l'essentiel du mouvement amorcé depuis
2017 par le gouvernement pour la justice
je veux parler ici de donner à la
justice les moyens de son ambition et
c'est comme cela que nous pourrons
assurer la souveraineté de la justice
française ainsi que sa grandeur avec une
augmentation de 503 millions d'euros par
rapport à 2023 soit 5,3 % le budget
dévolue à la justice est sans précédent
et à l'écoute des deux précédents
orateurs de l'opposition je sens bien
leur gêne s'il fallait le rappeler une
nouvelle fois je vous dirait que le
budget annuel de la justice passe de 6,9
milliards d'euros en 2017 6,9 milliards
d'euros en 2017 à plus de 10 milliards
d'euros en
2024 10,1 milliards d'euros pour être
plus
précis rapporteur thématique de la loi
de programmation 2023-2027 je me réjouis
donc tout particulièrement que que son
adoption le 10 septembre dernier
permettent de pérenniser les hausses de
moyens notre ambition ne s'arrête pas en
effet à cette loi de finance puisque
l'objectif est bien d'atteindre 11
milliards d'euros d'ici 2027 soit une
hausse de 60 % sur l'ensemble des deux
quinquenas reprenant vos mots monsieur
le garde des saau je dirais que cette
loi et le budget y afférant vont
renforcer notre justice en la rendant
plus proche plus protectce et plus
rapide pour chacun de nos concitoyens
c'est ce que je l'espère l'annonce de la
fin de l'état de délabrement avancé de
la justice dénoncé par les États
généraux de la justice et par certains
par certains par l'ancien garde des saau
monsieur hurvois c'est en tout cas la
fin de plus de 30 ans d'abandon
budgétaire pour la justice cette
proximité de la justice avec nos
concitoyens est essentiel tous doivent
connaître leurs droits et tous doivent
pouvoir les défendre c'est la raison
pour laquelle le groupe démocrate se
félicite que le budget du programme
Accès au droit et à la justice s'élève à
734,2 million d'euros pour 2024 et se
tradise notamment par une augmentation
de 16,1 million d'euros du budget
consacré à l'aide juridictionnel pour un
montant total de
657,1 million d'euros en parallèle
l'accélération du rythme de recrutement
et notamment la création de 327 postes
de magistrat 340 greffiers 400 attaché
de justice en 2024 participeront sans
aucun doute de cette proximité et de la
qualité de la justice rendue et parce
que la connaissance et l'accès à ces
droits par tout à chacun doit commencer
dès le plus jeune âge nous devons aussi
tourner notre politique judiciaire vers
nos enfants nous devons donner les
moyens à la justice des mineurs et à la
protection de l'enfance d'être au
rendez-vous et d'accompagner au mieux
ses enfants alors le code de la justice
pénale des mineurs qui est un succès
hein le le rapport qui vient d'être qui
vient d'être publié
à la demande des parlementaires
d'ailleurs euh et le dit sans sans aucun
sans aucune ambiguité
euh donc dans le cadre d'intervention
des professionnels de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse il faut
désormais offrir une prise en charge et
des réponses judiciaires adaptées euh
nous ne devons pas sur ce sujet relâcher
nos efforts l'augmentation de 28
millions d'euros du budget du programme
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
atteignant 950 millions d'euros pour
2024 est une nouvelle étape majeure
alors le groupe démocrate salue donc le
budget Allué à la justice pour 2024 vous
l'aurez compris monsieur le garde des
saau je n'ai pas vraiment de question
puisque nous nous le le la loi de
programmation trouve ses réponses trouve
ses réponses dans ce budget mais par
contre j'aurais une petite remarque sur
sur nos nos nos oppositions et en
particulier l'opposition et les filles
parce que je trouve pas très correct de
des choses qui sont même des
contevérités factuelles et de le tirer
de nos débats pour ensuite en faire des
belles petites vignettes pour votre pour
votre propagande internet mais nous
devons rappeler les faits notre justice
est aujourd'hui en voie de merci Madame
CÉC Madame C alors vous allez tous
pouvoir rester
calme on sait que les mensonges sont mon
courantes ici il suffit de les démasquer
madame cécileunter pour le groupe
socialiste merci
merci merci monsieur le Président je je
salue le travail des rapporteurs merci
monsieur le ministre de de vos propos
introductifs la première chose que nous
avons faite évidemment c'est d'aller
vérifier si la loi de programmation
était se concrétisait dans le budget et
fort heureusement vous étiez au
rendez-vous sinon ça n'aurait pas été
simple je pense rappelons que par un
amendement d'ailleurs de notre groupe au
30 avril de chaque année un rapport sera
remis au Parlement sur les créations
d'emplois et et de la consommation des
crédits ce qui me paraît tout à fait
intéressant d'un point de vue
mathématique de savoir comment tout cela
progresse alors moi j'ai cinq questions
la première c'est sur les greffiers mais
c'est très court monsieur le ministre
sur les greffi vous avez dit
qu'effectivement un accord était
intervenu moi je voulais appeler votre
attention sur le fait qu'il y a encore
des greffiers qui sont bien sûr en
catégorie A mais la catégorie A en
justice n'est pas la même que celle dans
d'autres administrations et nous de dev
devont me semble-t-il corriger ces
inégalités alors je n'ai pas le
sentiment que pour eux c'est un budget
historique vous allez nous dire
peut-être comment il pourrait considérer
qualifier ce budget comme historique au
regard des propositions que vous nous
ferez ma deuxème question c'est sur les
recrutements les recrutements c'est 2800
personnes 2800 magistrats d'ici
2027 c'est-à-dire 700 magistrats par an
à recruter c'est énorme c'est tout à
fait nécessaire et nous saluons ement le
budget la première étape c'était le
budget vous l'avez réussi la deuxième il
faut concrétiser ça ça va pas être
simple parce que vous avez à l'ENM une
promotion de 380 élèves vous en aurez
une 500 bon vous allez peut-être c'est
ma deuxième question comment
organisez-vous pensez-vous organiser par
l'ouverture à la magistrature ce
recrutement des 700 des 700 magistrats
ensuite ma trème question c'est sur
l'agis sur l'agis les crédits augmentent
de 22 millions c'est vrai que la Cour
des comptes fait des observations par
rapport à un manque de pilotage nous
nous vous proposons un pilotage
particulier c'est une expérimentation et
nous y tenons vraiment une une
expérimentation faisant que les enfants
de l'AZ qui n'ont personne auprès d'eux
pour les aider puisse bénéficier d'une
assistance systématique d'un avocat ça
n'est pas une procédure contre le juge
c'est pour aider le juge dans des
décisions qui sont extrêmement
douloureuses et nous le voyons nous dans
nos permanences nous sommes saisis
réguliè situation pour lesquelles hélas
nous ne pouvons pas agir ma 4è question
c'est sur les CF 20 CF là encore la Cour
des comptes fait un procès moi pour le
pour le coup je considère que c'est un
dispositif utile et important d'ailleurs
vous l'avez vous l'avez reconnu puisque
vous en créez 20 et que vous l'avez
reconnu dans notre département puisque
nous sommes en attente d'un
CF alors sur ce sujet je vous
souhaiterais savoir où on en est de même
que pour les prisons si vous pouvez nous
éclairer sur ce point et sur une
question qui est celle qui m'est posée
par la commune concernée par ce CF qui
serait que elle devrait céder son
terrain à à l'euro symbolique évidemment
elle ne se elle ne elle ne souhaite pas
s'engager dans cette voie et si vous
pouvez nous éclairer sur les modalités
de financement des CF et les efforts
demandés aux communes cela serait utile
me semble-t-il pour tout le monde ma
dernière question c'est sur la Cour des
comptes le rapport de 2023 qui dénonce
la tension persistante entre la
population carcérale et une une
politique d'exécution des peines qui
interroge courte peine - 23 % détention
provisoire + 30 % durée d'incarcération
plus 24 %, c'est les effets de bord des
6 mois on rallonge alors il y a une
recommandation qui est faite par la Cour
des comptes c'est de compléter le
dispositif statistique pour évaluer les
effets sur l'évolution des personnes
bénéficiant d'un aménagement d'une peine
de de celle effectivement incarcéré cela
me paraît tout à fait utile pour
détourner contester le dispositif du
bienfait de l'enfermement que nous
voyons sur notre droite régulièrement
répété merci merci Monsieur Philippe
Pradal pour le groupe
auison monsieur le garde des sa monsieur
le Président madamees messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues la mission
justice pour 2024 s'inscrit dans la
lignée ambitieuse du projet de loi de
programme tion et d'orientation de la
justice définitivement adopté par le
Parlement le 10 octobre permettez-moi
donc de rappeler rapidement que cette
loi de programmation venait d'une part
concrétiser les résultats des états
généraux de la justice menés en 2021 et
d'autre part entériner les réformes
structurelles portées par la précédente
loi de programmation 2018-2022 c'est
donc avec constance en concertation avec
les acteurs et en cohérence avec des
budgets en augmentation que nous
travaillons à transformer la justice
pour la rendre plus efficace et plus
accessible à tous les Français la loi
que nous venons de voter fixe donc la
trajectoire pluriannuelle du budget de
la justice d'ici 2027 d'un montant de
9,6 milliards d'euros en 2023 celui-ci
sera porté à 10,8 milliards d'euros
d'ici 4 ans soit hausse de 21 % sur le
quinquena
2022-2027 concernant l'émission justice
pour 2024 et conformément aux
engagements pris les autorisations
d'engagement sont en hausse de 13,72 %
et les crédits de paiement de 5,10 % par
rapport à 2023 nous tenons à saluer tout
particulièrement le renforcement des
moyens humains vous l'avez dit monsieur
le garde des saau avec 10000 emplois
créés au ministère de la Justice sur 5
ans
en 2024 parmi les 1961 emplois créés
1307 le seront dans les services
judiciaires magistrat équipe autour du
magistrat 450 dans l'administration
pénitentiaire en particulier pour
l'ouverture de nouveaux établissements
et 92 emplois dans la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse ses création
d'emploi s'ajoute au 605 précédemment
créé en 2023 l'amélioration des
conditions de détention avec un
programme immobilier pénitentiaire qui
prévoit la création de 15000 places de
préson supplémentair à l'horizon 2027 la
livraison de quatre nouveaux établis 570
places en tout est prévu en 2024 auquel
s'ajoutent les 36 opérations restantes à
livrer à l'heure où le travail dans les
établissements pénitentiaires souffre
d'un manque cruel d'attractivité nous
soutenons les budgets consacrés à la
revalorisation statutaire et
indemnitaire de la filière de
surveillance avec le passage de la
catégorie C à la catégorie B pour les
surveillants et sui de la catégorie B à
la catégorie A pour les officiers
saluons enfin les moyens consacrés à la
réduction des délais de traitement des
affaires judiciaires qui se sont
amélioré ces dernières années deux
questions monsieur le garde des si vous
permettez mais qui reprendront les
questions déjà posées concernant le
déploiement des nouvelles places de de
prison pouvez-vous nous faire un point
sur les attendus en 2024 et surtout
savoir comment les élus locaux
accueillent le le nécessaire et utile
besoin d'implantation dans leurs
communes des établissements
pénitentiaires et sur la transformation
numérique je sais votre engagement vers
un objectif zéro papier en 2027 il faut
reconnaître toutefois que les efforts
doivent être poursuivis notamment pour
améliorer le quotidien des agents
pourriez-vous nous indiquer quel
améliorations durables seront à attendre
pour 2024 et notamment s'il est envisagé
d'utiliser l'intelligence artificielle
dans le cadre des missions du ministère
de la justice par exemple pour procéder
à la recodification du code de procédure
pénale monsieur le garde des sa je vous
remercie et je conclus enant que le
groupe horizon et apparenté sonorera de
voter en faveur de cette mission
budgétaire telle qu'elle est
proposée merci Monsieur jérémyordanov
pour le groupe écologiste merci monsieur
le président monsieur le garde des saut
alors quelques questions en attendant le
493 parce que je crois on n'aura pas le
loisir de voter ces crédits
euh donc effectivement tout le monde a
salué l'effort budgettaire juste
simplement rappeler quand même euh d'où
l'on part vous l'avez déjà dit plusieurs
fois monsieur le ministre mais on a
aujourd'hui 9000 magistrats là où il en
faudrait 22000 pour atteindre les
standards européens idem pour les
greffiers on a 34 pour 100000 habitants
et si on veut être dans la moyenne
européenne c'est plutôt 61 pour 100000
on est aujourd'hui sur une justice de
l'urgence qui n qui n'écoute pas et qui
chronomètre tout et c'est on a une perte
de sens pour les pour les magistrats
pour l'ensemble des des agents de de la
justice et je suis pas certain que ce
budget et la répartition des crédits
permettent de de résoudre en réalité
cette perte de sens sur le taux
d'occupation des prisons on est à 120 %
143 % pour les maisons d'arrêt euh 5e
plus mauvais taux des 47 pays du Conseil
de l'Europe euh je passe sur les
condamnations on a une administration
pénitentiaire qui est délabré
euh je dis ça parce que il y a une forme
de maltraitance aujourd'hui du personnel
des justiciables et des détenus euh et
c'est ce à quoi il faut il faut répondre
et euh malheureusement on n'est pas
certain que encore une fois les crédit
euh permettent de de répondre à ça euh
la défense des plus vulnérables qui doit
être euh vraiment une priorité n'est pas
non plus forcément au rendez-vous l'aide
juridictionnelle par exemple ne tient
même pas compte de de
l'inflation vous comptez diviser par
deux le les délais de de jugement en
réalité sur le le nombre de magistrats
qui arrivent aujourd'hui dans les
tribunaux il y a vraiment rien qui
permet de de penser qu'on va y arriver
vous annoncer 327 magistrats
supplémentaires en en
2024 loin des des besoins recensés les
premiers référentiels établis par le
groupe d'étude sur la charge de travail
des magistrats démontent qu'il en
faudrait deux à trois fois plus voire
quatre fois plus pour par exemple
certaines fonctions comme
l'instruction mon groupe avait
expressément demandé à ce que ces
référentiels pilotés par la DSJ servent
de base à la construction du budget or
il n'en est rien et pire c'est ces
budgets ne sont pas diffusés ils sont
dans l'attente d'un contrôle de
cohérence on va vérifier les chiffres
donc ma question c'est quand seront
onont-ils publiés et à quoi serviront
ces référentiels est-ce qu'il serviront
à calculer le nombre de magistrats
nécessaires ou simplement à répartir euh
quelque part la
pénurie il faut bien avoir l'esprit que
cette indigence des moyens humains et
matériels empêche d'apporter une réponse
satisfaisante dans certaines matières
pourtant jugé prioritaire euh si l'on
croit on croit votre dernière circulaire
de politique pénale je pourrais prendre
l'exemple de la justice pénale
environnementale qui manque cruellement
d'assistants spécialisé dans les pôles
régionaux à moyen constant la justice ne
peut plus effectuer
efficacement ne peut plus lutter
efficacement contre les atteintes à
l'environnement je pourrais aussi
évoquer la lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales vous en faites une
politique pénale prioritaire mais la
justice fonctionne toujours là aussi à
moyen constant et les outils prometteurs
ne sont pas suffisamment mobilisés je
pense en particulier au contrôle
judiciaire avec placement probatoire le
cjpp aujourd'hui il y a 10 structures
qui existent avec seulement 165 places
pourquoi ne pas ne pas les augmenter il
faudrait un un triplement de de ces de
ces nombre de structures euh je vais pas
avoir le temps de tout développer mais
euh on a on a sur
le sur le sur la pardon je vais un peu
trop vite sur le punitif euh je voudrais
arriver sur sur la la rénovation du parc
pénitentiaire qui est les les moyens
sont en baisse en fait sur la rénovation
on est 10 fois inférieur à ce dédier à
la construction de nouvelles places de
prison il faudrait conclure monsieur
comment il faudrait conclure je vais
conclure ah oui c'est 4 minutes pardon
euh si vous pouvez nous parler des de la
prison de Vars s'il vous plaît et j'
termine là parce que j'ai plus le temps
merci bon madame Elsa fossillon pour le
groupe gauche démocrate républicaine euh
merci Monsieur le le président en
préalable je je remercie le le le
rapporteur Éric pouya pour avoir sonné
l'alerte sur la santé psychique des des
détenus j'espère que dans la les
commissaires des lois sauront ensuite
s'en saisir pour passer aux actes
puisqu'il y a vraiment urgence en la
matière la deuxième chose peut-être en
en première question monsieur le
ministre je voudrais savoir si vous
souhaitez vous que les 577 députés de la
représentation nationale puisse voter ce
budget justice ça c'est ma première ma
première question euh il en aura
d'autres ensuite après une invitation
peut-être à à plus de modestie sur les
qualif tif et de de la lobgie et et de
et du budget sur ce caractère historique
je j'essaie de vous remettre en mémoire
comme j'étais député en 2017 j'étais en
commission éducation et et je me
souviens qu'à peu près tous les ans le
ministre blanqueur nous parlait aussi de
budget historique et regardons l'état
aujourd'hui de l'école publique le T
l'attractivité pour le métier
d'enseignant et le nombre de de de de
profs qui ne sont pas remplacés dans les
écoles et peut-être ça c'est historique
peut-être que ça vous invitera à un peu
plus de modestie vu l'état de
délabrement aujourd'hui de de la justice
alors oui il y a des moyens
supplémentaires encore faut-il qu'il
soit mis au bon endroit et qu'il soit
dans une logique aussi qui permet de
répondre au au délabrement on a déjà dit
beaucoup de choses pour mon groupe lors
de de la lobgie donc évidemment on
pourrait être sur des redites puisque là
on est dans une tr traduction aussi de
ce que nous avons déjà dit en
juillet les états généraux de la justice
on on dit très bien et je rappelle les
termes qui était qui étaient présents il
disait c'était c'est un sentiment de
désespoir voire de honte qui domine face
au manque de moyens humains et matériel
d'appuie technique efficace et cohérent
face aussi aux réformes incessantes et à
l'impossibilité de bien remplir sa
mission alors que les contentieux
deviennent toujours plus complexe ça
c'est une des choses évidemment
auxquelles il faut s'attaquer et dès
qu'il y a quelques moyens supplément
entaires qui sont mis pour des
personnels évidemment ils prennent et
ils ont bien raison de prendre mais là
et on vous l'avait déjà dit leur lors de
la lobgie ce à quoi ne s'attaque pas ce
budget ni les les textes votés
précédemment c'est à une réorganisation
globale de l'institution à une réforme
plus systémique et c'est bien à ça
auquel nous vous appelons notamment et
j'en ai suffisamment parler mais je ne
cesserai de le faire sur la question de
la sortie du du tout carcéral et la
nécessité de s'attaquer à euh la
surpopulation galopante à tous ces
matelas au sol et à l'indignité que cela
confèt aux détenus mais aussi au fait
que ça affecte considérablement le sens
de la peine et les possibilités euh de
de réinsertion j'avais envie de de vous
interroger après ce rappel sur ce que
nous avions déjà dit sur la question euh
des personnels pénitentiaires et plus
spécifiquement sur la question euh des
surveillants euh pénitentiaires euh si
je ne me trompe pas pour de 2024 c'est
512 surveillants
supplémentaires la moitié d'entre eux
seront sur les les nouvelles places de
de prison j'aimerais savoir quels sont à
la fois les chiffres prévus pour les
années les années suivantes c'est-à-dire
le plan la ventilation entre entre place
actuelle et nouvelle place et surtout si
vous avez l'objectif d'un taux
d'encadrement au aujourd'hui enfin infin
pour 2027 pour les surveillants
pénitentiaire je l'ai déjà rappelé mais
quand nous sommes allés avec Madame Abad
au Pays-Bas nous avons constaté qu'il y
avait un taux d'encadrement environ de
un surveillant pour 12 détenus on est
sur un idéal absolument colossal mais
peut-être avons-nous un idéal français
sur le nombre de surveillants
pénitentiirees par rapport au nombre de
détenus parce que pour le moment c'est
plutôt la honte monsieur Jean-Félix à
pour le groupe liberté indépendant autre
ma et
territoire merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues on ne peut
nier les efforts budgétaire conséquent
pour 2024 acté dans la toute récente loi
de programmation les crédit de paiement
de la mission justice pour l'année qui
vient progresse en hausse de 5 % sur un
an cette hausse budgétaire est bien
évidemment bienvenue mais nous
considérons qu'il faut ici parler
clairement de politique judiciaire dans
sa globalité et sur C certains points
récurrents et problématique donc la
mission tendance je concentrerai mon
propos sur trois points le premier étant
la surpopulation carcérale
l'administration pénitencière demeure le
programme le plus lourd financièrement
du ministère mais également le plus en
souffrance en dépit des 5 milliards
d'euros qui lui sont dédiés la
pénitentiaire doit sans cesse faire face
aux mêmes difficulté sur population
carcérale quasi ingérable manque
d'attractivité des métiers donc manque
de cant d'ffectifs radicalisation en
prison particulièrement problématique
politique d'insertion à redynamiser
entre autres la politique de
restauration menée lors de la précédente
législature nous semble pas avoir mené
pour nous en tout cas au résultat
annoncés notre groupe s'inquiète en
particulier des conditions indignes de
détention de certains sites qui ont déjà
valué la France plusieurs condamnations
par la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme on enregistre ça été dit avant
moi un taux d'occupation des places en
maison d'arrêt de 141 % contre 131 %
l'année d'avant une agrévation de 10
points en un an enemp des 15000
nouvelles places annoncées nous
craignons qu'aucune perspective
d'amélioration de pote à court terme les
retards et difficultés dans la
construction semblent s cubulé la
situation d'autant plus grave en notre
mer en Guadeloupe les deux sites
affichent des taux d'occupation de plus
de 135 % à Mayotte la prison de magicavo
dépasser 250 % le garde des saau que
vous êtes cétait engagé l'année dernière
à créer un nouveau centre à Mayotte je
me permettrai de poser une première
question pourriez-vous nous dire où on
est ce projet deème point les moyens
dédiés aux juridictions judiciaaires là
encore les crédit progressent c'est vrai
et le plan de recrutement de 1500
magistrats et de 1800 greffiers a débuté
cependant les juridiction t zones
confondu enregistre toujours des délais
de jugement élevés en matière de civil
notamment le stock d'affaires depuis le
covid ne semble toujours pas résorbé le
risque est désormais celui d'un
aggravation de la fracture territoriale
dans le fonctionnement et l'accès à
notre service public de la justice
territorialement si vous proposez des
mesures dédié au territoire exposé à des
difficultés d'attractivité certaines
juridictions notamment ce n'est pas
nouveau dans notre bouche les autres
maires et la Corse souffrent toujours
d'un manque de personnel qui ne sera pas
résolu par le biais de dispositions
temporair nous avons besoin d'effectif
durable je rappelle à cette occasion les
avis des bâtonniers particulièrement de
cors qui rejoignent celui de l'Assemblée
de Corse pour eux il s'agit presque
d'une régression toute porte à croire
que les magistrats qui seront affectés
temporairement resteront finalement sur
le continent ces derniers exerceront
essentiellement par des moyens de
communication audiovisuelle dans la
mesure où ils seront simplement détachés
de la cour d'appel de Paris ou
d'exenprence il y a en effet peu de
chance qu'un déplacement en cor sur une
périe de 3 mois soit tout simplement
possible car dans ces juridiction
importantes et encombré les effectifs
sont pesés d'autre part sur la question
de l'aide juridictionnelle si elle
totalise une hausse de 21 million
d'euros en un an la rétribution des
avocats que vous connaissez bien pose
toujours question le Conseil National
des Barreaux demande revalorisation de
la rétribution de l'aide
juridictionnelle en faisant passer
l'unité de valeur de 36 à 42,2 € hors
taxe nous demandons par ailleurs une
adaptation de ce montant en outreemère
et une réduction des délais de paiement
nettement plus éevé que dans l'Hexagone
avec par exemple 4 mois de délai la
Réunion alors que l'objectif est d'un
paiement en 30 jours pour finir je
profite de l'examen la mission justice
pour appeler n deux réformes sur
lesquell nous voudrions avoir votre
point de vue tout d'abord la refonte du
statut des repentis qui doit permettre
de rendre le dispositif plus incitatif
afin de mieux lutter contre les
phénomènes mafieux un texte serait en
préparation pouvez nous nous en dire
plus ensuite vous le savez nous plaidons
pour un renforcement des pouvoirs de la
grasque afin d'améliorer la saisie et la
gestion des biens et sommes saisis lors
de procédure pénal notre groupe a déposé
une proposition de loi portée par jean-l
varsman nous demandons une nouvelle fois
une inscription du jour lors des
prochaines semaine à l'Assemblée je vous
remercie monsieur le Président merci
enfin Madame Ménard pour le Emmanuel
Ménard pardon pour le les non
inscrits merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous nous avez dit
en introduction que le défi n'était pas
de savoir si nous allions recruter mais
si nous allions trouver des candidats
alors comme monsieur camardine je dirais
que si vous voulez trouvez monsieur le
ministre envoyez-les à Bézier s'il vous
plaît il nous manque en effet au moins
un juge des enfants et lors des
dialogues de gestion 2022 la Direction
des Services judiciaaires a confirmé
qu'il manque à baiser plusieurs
magistrats du cège pour pouvoir traiter
convenablement son activité
juridictionnelle elle a en effet relevé
un risque de surcharge avec 1316
affaires civiles et pénales traité par
magistrat pour 656 en moyenne pour les
autres juridictions du groupe 3 soit un
écart de plus de 100 %. par ailleurs
l'annonce de la création d'un centre de
rétention administrative de 120 places à
bzier ce dont je me félicite rend
indispensable la création d'un troisème
poste de juge de liberté et de la
détention avant son ouverture effective
par ailleurs toujours à Bézier
évidemment la circulaire de localisation
des emplois prévoit ne9u postes de
magistrat au parquet depuis 2021
malheureusement il faut noter que le
compte n'y est pas avec un poste vacant
actuellement suite à un départ non
remplacé et toujours lors des dialogues
de gestion 2022 la direction des
services judiciaires a relevé 2964
affaires traitées par magistrat du
parquet de Bézier ce qui est assez
nettement supérieur plus 11 % au ratio
des autres juridictions du groupe 3 avec
2678 affaires traitées par magistrat du
parquet il faut signaler que là encore
l'activité du parquet de Bézier est en
constante augmentation on témoigne le le
nombre de déferement qui était de 743 en
2020 909 en 2021 et 1027 en 2022 enfin
la circulaire de localisation des
emplois prévoit 92 poste de greffe toute
catégorie confondu le poste de directeur
principal de greffe est vacant depuis le
1er décembre 2021 suite à un départ à la
retraite l'intérim est assuré par une
directrice des services de greffe mais
il n'y a pour le moment aucune
candidature pour pouvoir se poste vacant
un poste de greffier est également
vacant euh je vais terminer euh en
parlant du centre pénitentiaire je je
conclus là-dessus qui attend toujours
son système antiprojection certainert un
peut dépasser aujourd'hui puisque le
personnel pénitentiaire doit maintenant
faire face à des livraisons par drone de
façon quotidienne mais qui n'ont pas été
dotés de système de brouillage
anti-drone alors vous le voyez monsieur
le ministre nos besoins sont énormes et
ma seule allez monsieur le ministre vous
pouvez vous vous avez eu 2 minutes 15
j'éta j'étais un peu plus généreux
monsieur le ministre pour vot réponses
aux orateurs de groupe et avant la les
différents questions de nos collègues
merci monsieur le Président d'abord
peut-être une fois n'est pas coutume je
je je ne vais pas répondre par ordre
chronologique je vais grouper une
première question qui semble taroder à
la fois madame céillon monsieur jordanov
et Monsieur
Shrek je veux rappeler que le budget
justice a été voté l'année dernière et
je sais pas pourquoi pris d'un d'un d'un
d'un d'un pessimisme soudain ou d'une
forme de repentance al que ce que j'ai
cité n'ont pas forcément voté
mais vous évoquez un
493 enfin vous constatez à la fois que
on est dans les clous de la loi de
programmation que certains d'entre vous
je le rappelle monsieur
Shrek ont voté et là vous me dites 493
mais qu'est-ce qui vaut soudain ce ce
pessimisme Mo bien sûr que moi moi bien
sûr que j'entends que on a on aille au
bout des choses parce que les autres
années certains à tout pur miséricorde
n'étaient pas au rendez-vous de ces
budgets qui permettaiit quand même à la
justice un meilleur fonctionnement je
veux pas rappeler ici parce que gr grâce
au budget précédent on a embauché en de
magistrat de greffi et de
contractuel plus de 700 magistrats
euh sous le quinquen de Monsieur Holland
c'est nettement nettement nettement
moins que ça on dépasse pas les 150
magistrats et sous celui du président
Sarkozi c'est un chiffre négatif parce
qu'on remplaçait pas ceux qui étaaient à
la retraite donc grâce à ces budgets on
a déjà fait beaucoup de choses ils ont
été votés moi je oui j'entends t que il
le soit enfin l'objectif commun c'est
c'est c'est donner à la justice des
moyens dont elle a dont elle a
impérieusement besoin bon alors ayant
dit cela je reprends le cours ordinaire
et chronologique des réponses que je
dois à la représentation nationale mon
Président Terlier vous avez souligné me
semble-t-il la juste raison la nécessité
de corréler les recrutements
l'immobilier les moyens informatiques je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est une
approche global et c'est le prisme
d'ailleurs par lequel nous présentons le
présent
budget monsieur le rapporteur Éric
pouill vous m'avez posé plusieurs
questions la la première est relative
aux extractions médicales c'est un sujet
important la
DAP organise ses service de sorte que
les extractions médicales puissent être
réalisé il peut arriver c'est vrai que
certaines consultations en excluant bien
sûr les urgences soient reportées je
veux néanmoins souligner même si c'est
euh un ordre de grandeur que plus de
50000 extractions médicales sont
réalisées chaque année et que ce chiffre
a plus que doublé entre
entre entre 2020 et
2023 pour compléter le dispositif
d'offre de soix soin en complément des
extractions médicales tout un travail
autour de la télémédecine qui est
actuellement conduit et le projet le
projet de déploiement de la télésanté au
sein des unités sanitaires en milieu
pénitentiaire a été vous le savez lancé
en 2021 avec le concours de la direction
générale de l'offre de soins et un
financement de l'ordre de
2800000 € du fond pour la transformation
de l'action publique voilà le projet
comprend la mise à niveau du câblage
sécurité des systèmes d'information
création d'un catalogue de des
spécialités médicales proposé et cette
solution viendra non pas remplacer mais
à l'évidence améliorer les prises en
charge sanitaire vous m'avez également
interpellé monsieur le rapporteur sur la
distance pour réaliser les transferts
vers les
UHSA les équipes pénitentiaires des UHSA
chargé de cette ces transferts ont la
possibilité de programmer et d'anticiper
ces manœuvres de transfert elles sont
nécessairement réalisées car il s'agit
d'une admission en hospitalisation
généralement supérieure à 48h et ces
transferts sont
réalisés vous m'avez également
interpellé sur la seconde phase de
construction des trois nouvelles
euh UHSA c'est effectivement prévu 160
places supplémentaires en Normandie
hôpital rouvrait à à sateville les ran
60 places en région Occitanie sur la
commune de de Bézier madame Ménard même
si vous ne m'avez pas posé la question
40 places et et oui mais je vous je vous
répondrai je vous promets non mais bzier
je pense
évidemment à vous et aux questions que
m'avz posé et en île-de-fance hôpital
Ballanger à H sousbois 60
places sur le développement du contrôle
judiciaire avec placement probatoire
vous le savez le dispositif a été mis en
place fin 2020 au sein de deux sites nî
et Colmar j'ai décidé de
l'étendre à H sites complémentaires afin
d'assurer une réponse qui semble adaptée
au besoins de chaque ressort et en
assurant un maillage cohérent sur
l'ensemble du territoire un site par
direction interrégionale Bordeaux tour
Amien Cayen Draguignan Saint-Étienne
Paris et Rennes depuis
2022 et le cjpp comprend désormais 65
places pour une dotation de
2,6 millions d'euros monsieur le
président de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée national vous m'avez posé
beaucoup de
questions à vrai dire et je vais tenter
d'y répondre d'abord quels sont les
blocages administratifs locaux qui
demeurent et euh je vais naturellement
vous répondre parce qu'ils sont
essentiellement concentrés sur cinq
projets suivants qui
comptabilise
3235 places je répète 3000 235 places
Noiseau
800 places
Magnanville 700 places
crisenois 1000 places Orléan 120 places
Muray 615
places voilà je pense qu'il est inutile
d'apporter d'autres précisions chacun y
reconnaîtra les siens voilà la
difficulté elle est là euh on veut plus
de construction on veut plus de place on
veut plus voilà
mais
ailleurs et c'est une des difficultés et
quand on parle d'ailleurs euh euh
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas entendu ce
griief mais je je l'anticipe il
reviendra il revient de façon récurrente
quand on parle des retards je veux dire
qu'ils sont 3 He de les retards d'abord
le temps qu'on a mis pour trouver les
terrains et je vous promets que c'est
pas une promenate de santé sans mauvais
jeux de mots c'est vraiment compliqué
deuxièmement il y a eu la covid bien sûr
et troisièmement la guerre en Ukraine
avec une difficulté de se fournir en
matériaux voilà la réalité alors moi je
je je veux bien tout ce que on veut
quand j'ai travaillé et je suis très
heureux de l'avoir fait notamment avec
Eric cioti sur ces questions je pense
qu'il était d'une parfaite sincérité je
le suis également mais nous avons dit
pour ces 3000 places et bien regardez
d'ailleurs le rapport annexé on a quand
même une difficulté c'est que il faut
que vous nous donniez un coup de main et
il y a la coconstruction du texte et
puis il y a la coconstruction j'allais
dire réelle des établissements péniten
Truel et ciment compris donc je je ne
peux que redire la même chose moi je
suis partant pour cela je me suis
exprimer longuement
devant devant le Parlement
ensuite l'accord sur l'accord avec le
les greffiers je vais vous dire un tout
petit mot de la difficulté à laquelle
j'ai été
confronté certains greffiers
souhaita
d'autres
souhaitaent de
l'indicière déjà compliqué de d'avoir
deux revendications
distinctes dans les dans c'est ce qu'on
a fait monsieur vous faites bien d'en
parler c'est exactement ce qu'on a fait
dans l'exposé syndical puisque les
syndicats sont naturellement mes
interlocuteurs il y avait les mêmes
divergences donc nous avons fait les
deux voyez et je vous annonce que nous
devrions je le mets encore au
conditionnel à cet
instant signer un accord cette
semaine voilà ça me paraît absolument
indispensable qu'on le dise et et je
veux redire ici vous l'avez exprimé et
je suis en plein accord avec vous nous
avons nous devons rendre hommage à nos
greffiers nous avons besoin d'eux il y a
pas de justice
sansreffier et ils appartiendront je le
redis à l'équipe auutour du magistrat
que nous allons
constituer monsieur le député breton
avec des contractuels qui contrairement
au précédent vont être pérénisés ils
vont s'appeler attacher de justice ils
vont être pérénisé cédisé ils vont
prêter serment euh qu'est-ce que vous
m'avez demandé ensuite ah oui monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
vous m'avez parlé de l'AMIA alors j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure quelque chose qui
me plaît pas du tout on dire ouais
l'amiable c'est une façon de je je euh
l'amiable c'est une façon euh pour le
pour le juge d'être recentré dans son
cœur de métier dire le droit trancher le
litige
l'amiable c'est également
une un mode de de de de de justice où le
justiciable se réapproprie son procès
vous vous savez il y a des procès
aujourd'hui il faut 2 ans et demi 3 ans
de mise en état parfois le justiciire
voit pas son juge et si vous saviez on
en reparlera tout à l'heure mais dans un
instant si vous saviez le nombre de
magistrats d'avocats de notairire de
commissairire de justice engagé
aujourd'hui sur l'amiable et je rappelle
que le top départ c'est 1er novembre
alors c'est pas du tout pour grappiller
pour aller vite vous bon voilà vous avez
cette vision c'est au contraire pour
pour rendre une justice plus proche et
plus rapide et au bénéfice de nos
compatriotes et à l'étranger où on est
allé on a constaté que l'amiable était
désormais le mode de règlement des
différents le plus euh utilisé 80 à 60 %
selon les pays ça a beaucoup de sens
alors la critique évidemment bon je je
je je je je l'entends mais
euh non j'ai j'ai j'ai compris madame m
mailleur je je sais bien mais il faut
que cette expérience soit tentée parce
qu'elle a beaucoup de sens pour le
justiciable
pardon j'y viens j'y viens je pense
qu'on est on est raccord là-dessus et et
vous qui connaissez bien la justice vous
savez que c'est c'est une bonne solution
c'est pas ce que j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure chez LFI là bon de façon pour
avoir un compliment de votre part il
faut quand même se lever de bonheur
bon
[Musique]
ouais alors monsieur le Président
enfin qu'est-ce que vous m'avez posé les
plac net 2023 11 établissements 2016
places et nous aurons atteint les 4300
places d'ici fin 2023 sur les 15000
voilà
madame la vice-présidente Caroline o
est- carolineors là aussi beaucoup
beaucoup de questions bon je vais me
faire un plaisir répondre alors d'abord
où en sont les négociations avec les
représentants de la
profession on doit signer dans
les qu'est-ce qui vous arrive vous AZ un
malaise on doit signer dans les heures
qui
viennent on a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
discuté avec
lffier j'ai rappelé un certain nombre de
chiffres il y a déjà eu des
revalorisations qui sont intervenu entre
parenthèses les chiffres que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure ne sont pas les
bons parce que il faut envisager
évidemment prime et et évidemment
salaire s'agissant des magistrats s'agit
de prime bon donc on espère
obtenir on espère obtenir des des des
accords très prochainement sur la DPJJ
bon sur milieu ouvert et placement
euh sur le milieu ouvert il y a un
travail qui va être mené sur les
modalités d'organisation des services
qui ont été impacté par la réforme du
CJPM et une réflexion va également être
engagée sur les indicateurs qualitatifs
d'activité et de performance pour en
réalité évaluer l'action des
professionnels de milieu ouvert et
allouer les ressources utiles à leur
mission on le
fait sur placement l'objectif c'est
évidemment d'améliorer l'offre de
placement au pénal garantir un cadre
sécurisé pour les mineurs placés et bien
sûr les profession
plan d'action qui vise une meilleure
préparation des orientations de
placement et un assouplissement du
fonctionnement des structures
d'hébergement qui sera testé madame la
vice-présidente dès dès
2024 2024 c'est une autre question vous
me posiez j'ai déjà répondu quatre
nouveaux établissements pénitentiaires
seront livré Toulon noisilgrand Colmar
nî et trois sites pénitentiaires
finaliseront leur première phase de
travaux c'est Bordeaux Bordeaux
Gradignan Baster et et bmao sur les
pôles
spécialisés alors le dispositif du cjpp
se se distingue de la prise en charge
offerte au sein des centres de prise en
charge des auteurs de violence conjugale
euh et sur les pôles spécial je vais y
revenir dans une seconde je vous pris de
m'excuser le décret est en Conseil
d'État euh madame la députée Chandler le
le sa je crois euh concertation avec
tous les acteurs le principe la
confiance dans les acteurs locaux
puisque vous savez que dans les états
généraux évidemment c'est quelque chose
qui revenu très très très souvent
déconcentrant et cetera et c'est la
raison pour laquelle madame madame
Ménard tout à l'heure vous me faisiez le
dialogue de gestion en direct live et en
exclusivité si vous me permettez ces
angl que je n'aime pas mais les
dialogues de gestion désormais ils se
font cours d'appel par cours d'appel et
c'est les cours d'appel qui affecteront
les magistrats les greffiers les
contractuels qui vont être envoyés
pourquoi parce que les cours d'appel
savent mieux
que que nous les besoins du terrain
c'est c'était une revendication des
chefs de cours
alors voilà les les les moyens en hausse
viendront effectivement favoriser la
mise en œuvre de ces pô puis il y avait
une dernière question sur le cjpp qui se
distingue de la prise en
charte offerte au sein des des des
centres de prise en charge des auteurs
de violence conjugale le cjpp ne se
substitue pas au cpc1 mais il vient en
améliorer en réalité l'efficacité
comment en favorisant l'articulation des
interventions judiciaires sociales et
sanitaires dans un objectif
bien sûr de protection des
victimes le ministère de la Justice ne
finance ni ne cofinance les coûts qui
sont liés aux hébergements vous
savez aux ressources humaines des CPCA
et au prise en charge individuel
collective financement 70 % direction
générale de la cohésion sociale et 30 %
cofinancement non justice et enfin les
cjpp prennent en charge les conjoints
viol
qui présente une dangerosité importante
je pense avoir à peu près répondu aux
questions que vous avez évoqué monsieur
Shrek bon monsieur Shrek je vous ai
d'abord adressé un petit mot liminaire
pour vous dire que je comprenais pas
votre
pessimisme non parce que à partir du
moment où vous dites que le texte il est
que je présente budget et dans les clous
de la loi de programmation que vous avez
voté bon enfin peu importe alors il y a
deux ou trois petites choses qu'il
convient de rectifier j'ai déjà tenté de
le faire
précédemment nous avons évoqué déjà
cette
question la trajectoire budgétaire
pluriannuelle du ministère tient compte
des hypothèses d'inflation qui sont tenu
par Bery qui prévoi 3 % en moyenne
annuelle en 24 2,1 % en 25 1,75 % en
2026 et 27 ça je tiens à le rappeler le
niveau de consommation des crédits c'est
une autre de vos préoccupation entre
2021 et 2022 reste élevé et en
amélioration par rapport au 8862
millions de crédits votés en 2022
l'exécution effective a atteint
8792 millions d'euros soit une
différence monsieur Schrek de seulement
60 100 million c'est équivalent à 0,8 %
des crédits votés et par rapport à 2021
ce taux de sous-exécution est en baisse
il passe de 1,8 en 2021 à 0,8 en
2022 ce qui souligne une amélioration de
l'exécution de nos crédits et sur les 15
dernières années le taux de
sous-exécution est inférieur à 1 % ce
qui est disons-le eu assez faible
euh monsieur
couom bon vous avez
oublié petit détail sans doute à vos
yeux mais euh toutes ces mesures que que
que que je porte cette envie de
renforcer les personnels et cetera euh
ça provient des États généraux c'est pas
mes Lubis répressives ou je ne sais quoi
là
et et dans les états généraux ben il y a
eu des tas de consultations qui ont été
faites et oui madame oui bien sûr et
tout le monde est venu sauf un seul
syndicat dont je don je sais qu'il est
assez proche de vous mais sinon tout le
monde est venu tout le monde mais tout
le monde est venu les magistrats les
greffiers les avocats les forces de
sécurité
intérieure les syndicats on a constitué
des groupes de travail moi moi moi je ne
suis pas intervenu pour que
véritablement de ces groupes de travail
et des deux vagues de consultation il
yit un certain nombre de grandes mesures
et vous y êtes totalement opposé c'est
quand même extraordinaire de penser que
l'amélioration du service public de la
justice ne vous intéresse pas c'est
extraordinaire on veut embaucher des
magistrats
desgffiers des contractuels qui vont
être cédisés des personnels pénit re
vous vous en moquez on pas plus
compliqué que ça vous ne voulez pas
améliorer la justice de notre
pays c'est pas plus non ben non je je je
je caricature tellement peu madame que
vous n'avez jamais voté un seul budget
justice et que pour la loi de
programmation vous vous êtes levé
immédiatement pour dire on en discute
même pas et souffre qu' soit pas
d'accord avec ah mais moi je veux bien
que vous ne soyez pas d'accord avec moi
et souffrez aussi que je ne sois pas
d'accord avec vous mais au moins qu'il y
ait un débat madame les choses sont
dites on vous avez immédiatement déposé
un amendement pour
demander la suppression voilà globale
donc vous irez quand vous irez en
juridiction et je vais vous dire c'est
extraordinaire la fois dernière j'ai
fait un déplacement je vais pas vous
dire où mais c'est un député de chez
vous il m'a dit quand je suis arrivé
devant le tribunal judiciaire ah mais
monsieur le ministre je vais surveiller
alors vraiment de façon très très
précise l'arrivée des magistrats
desgffiers je vous avez le texte gonflé
je ajouter qu'il y avait deux caméras de
télévision voilà allez donc l'inflation
j'ai déjà répondu la politique carcérale
monsieur il y a absolument pas
d'idéologie mais il s'agit voyez-vous je
vais vous rappeler un petit détail la
justice de notre pays est indépendante
voyez-vous
et la surpopulation
carcérale et tous les chiffres qu'
s'agisse des quantums correctionnels ou
des quantum criminels et la Cour des
comptes et la Cour des comptes
désormais monsieur Shrek la Cour des
comptes non non mais je je vous vois
doeliner et et j'ai et j'ai cru
comprendre que ça n'était pas un
inquiessement alors moi je je dis ça je
prêche dans le désert parce que vous
dites que la justice est l'xiste bon ok
mais la Cour des comptes dit mais oui
mais la Cour des comptes dit le
contraire vous voyez et la surpopulation
carcérale dit des choses et et et et et
et et l'examen des peines qui sont
prononcées le dit également bon alors
moi je vais vous rappeler que la justice
de ce pays voyez est indépendante que
nous sommes dans un état de droit et
enfin Monsieur Coulou je vais vous dire
entre mon arrivée en 2020 et et et
2024 les hausses par direction ont été
très importante DJ + 36 % DAP + 26 PJJ +
sg+ 52 voilà et la ha la plus important
contrairement à ce que vous affirmez
c'est pas pour la DAP c'est pour la DSJ
monsieur faut pas raconter n'importe
quoi n'importe comment voilà c'est pas
vrai ce que vous
dites
alors Monsieur monsieur breton bon
monsieur breton
l'
l' dispose de ressources financières
augmente en 2024 de plus 16 millions
d'euros je rappelle pas les différentes
augmentations qui sont intervenu mais
globalement depuis 2017 monsieur le
député la J a bénéficié d'une hausse de
80 % de budget supplémentaire on est
passé de 364 millions d'euros en 2017 à
657 millions d'euros en
2024 donc il faut quand même se souvenir
de ces chiffres il ils sont
impressionnants sur l'inflation j'ai
j'ai déjà répondu sur les contractuels
aussi puisque en fait en fait ces
contractuels d'abord ils
sont
diplômés ils sont titularisés cdisés ils
vont prêter serment et ils vont
constituer l'un des viviers pour euh euh
les futurs titulaires et ils
seront extrêmement importants pour
également venir comment
dirais-je j'ai presque envie de dire
régler cette question de l'embauche car
madame untermerer vous l'avez dit et et
je le dis aussi le défi pour nous va
être d'embaucher comment on le fait bah
nos écoles tournent à plein il y a ces
contractuels et il y a il a également
l'amélioration il faut s'en souvenir
des possibilités pour d'autres
professions du droit de de de venir dans
la magistrature on a notamment
considérablement simplifié vous le savez
bien les voies d'accès à la magistrature
on a réduit le nombre de concours on a
réduit également la durée des stages qui
très souvent étit des obstacles
infranchissables pour les professions du
droit donc voilà ce que nous allons
faire monsieur breton vous m'avez
interpellé monsieur le député
sur sur la question de de l'agis des
aides juridictionnelles du pilotage
avant le rapport de la Cour des comptes
nous nous souhaitions intervenir je dois
dire que les avocats eux-mêmes sétaient
émus de quoi parle-t-on on parle de
certains dossiers qui durent très
longtemps et où un certain nombre
d'avocats ont beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de clients et on multiplie le bénéfice
de l'AG et ça donne des sommes qui sont
exorbitantes et que certains avocats
dénoncent même voilà quand un avocat
n'est pas au bénéfice de l'AG il prend
les honoraires qu'il veut c'est
librement discuté entre l'avocat et le
client quand il est au bénéfice de l'AG
il y a matier à se poser quelques
questions et nous sommes en train de
travailler cette question et et je veux
le dire parce que c'est une réalité nous
avions anticipé de régler cette question
avant même que la Cour des comptes nous
dise ce qu'elle a eu raison de nous dire
voilà donc je suis en phase avec vous
sur sur cette sur cette
question je te presse un peu car il nous
reste 10 questions
voilà bon les
CF moi je je je je crois totalement au
CF le rapport de la Cour des comptes
appel à une évaluation elle est
évidemment nécessaire on va la faire
voilà je vais aller plus vite mais ça
n'est pas une volonté pour moi de de ne
pas répondre à la représentation
nationale c'est une expression bonne
administrationion voilà c'est le
président qui l'a dit bon
heran balanan monsieur le
député vous me posez pas de question
donc si si je m'attarde sur vos
remarques pour dire je suis d'accord
avec vous je je je vais me faire
réprimander par le
président madame la députée
ununtermerer bon la question des
catégories A pour les greffier
évidemment que vous avez raison qu'il
faut le prendre en compte recrutement
unm j'ai déjà répondu augmentation de
l'AG
oui je pense avoir grosso modo répondu à
tout à part peut-être à
l'expérimentation avocat en en a
euh bon et par des conventions locales
je rappelais que relative à l'aide
juridique le ministèreoc 3 au barreau
qui sont signataires une dotation
complémentaire en fonction des
permanences qui sont assurées et des
engagements du barreau et au 31 non
d'accord mais ça permet aussi d'aller là
où vous souhaitez que on aille davantage
peut-être en en décembre 2022 il y a 117
barreaux qui ont pris des engagements et
il y a une réflexion qui sera menée
comme prévu d'ailleurs je rappelle dans
dans le rapport annexé sur cette
question bon la livraison de du CF qui
vous chef de votre cœur je me permets de
le dire
ouais exactement et bien
sûr mais là j'ai le
terrain
Terra voilà on dispose du soutien des
élus de cette commune je tiens
d'ailleurs à le dire et et et
et mais l'association qui conduit le
projet et la ville sont mis d'accord sur
un montant d'acquisition du terrain
après évaluation des domaines et le
ministère a donné son accord de principe
pour le tarif convenu voilà
bon monsieur le député Philippe euh euh
Pradal euh alors déploiement numérique
mais je vais aller je vais aller un peu
vite là
euh il est évident que moi je veux pas
de juge robot ça me pas une absolue
évidence sinon d'ailleurs j'engagerai
pas des recrutements massifs euh
l'intelligence artificiellef évidemment
c'est un réel potentiel qu'on ne peut
pas rejeter d'un d'un revers de manche
dans ce domaine qui est notre comme dans
d'autres et vous le savez le 19
septembre dernier la première ministre a
installé un comité de l'intelligence
artificielle générative dont les travaux
ont vocation à éclairer au fond les
choix ultérieurs du Gouvernement en la
matière
euh
vous souhaitez également
euh sur les établissements pénitentiires
j'ai j'ai répondu je je je je n'y
reviens pas je ne veux pas fâcher le
président la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale monsieur Yordanov
493 j'ai j'ai j'ai répondu
euh sur population bon j'ai dit qu'on y
mettait les moyens il y a le plan 15000
il y a la libération sous contrainte que
vous oubliez souvent il y a des
alternatives à l'incarcération lorsque
elle est possible et justifié et que
naturellement le juge en décide et puis
il y aura
aussi une réflexion que nous allons
conduire bien sûr sur ces questions
euh madame madame madame Elsa
fossillon merci pour ce cours de
sémantique mais historique signifie en
réalité qu'on n jamais vu dans
l'histoire et pardon cela n'a rien à
voir avec mon immodestie je j'accepte
d'ailleurs vol
de vous concéder en confession mais ça a
en réalité à voir avec la réalité parce
que 60 % d'augmentation du budget depuis
l'élection du Président de la République
bah si vous me trouvez ça ailleurs je
m'incline moi et je dis que ça n'est pas
historique je dis que c'est déjà vu dans
l'histoire quand on avait des budgets je
ve pas citer les ministres vous les
reconnaîtrez je n'en doute pas une seule
seconde avec des augmentations de 1 %
voyez etad madame a reconnu tout de
suite à qui je fais allusion ça n'est
pas la seule d'ailleurs pour dire les
choses et et et
oui voilà alors
oui oui mais l'Allemagne vous oubliez un
certain nombre de choses c'est que
d'abord le rapport spège qui est votre
qui est votre guide à toujours 2 ans de
retard c'est la prière chose que je veux
dire que deuxièmement le rapport spège
ne prend pas en compte les juges
consulaires à qui je veux rendre hommage
parce que sont des juges bénévoles le
rapport spège ne prend pas en compte les
conseillers prudomour et troisièmement
monsieur le député sachez que le rapport
spège dit de façon clair que le droit
allemand est est est moins gourmand que
le nôtre en en en en magistrat
prenez-les aussi en considération et
puis au lieu de dire il y a toujours si
qui va pas il y a toujours C qui va pas
est-ce qu'une fois de temps en temps on
pourrait dire ben quand même on a
amélioré un peu les choses bon voilà
stop chacun prend ses
responsabilité voilà je prends les
miennes prenez les vôtrres monsieur quoi
Monsieur s'il vous plaît mais si j'ai
répondu bien sûr puis je suis poussé à
ma gauche
regardez monsieur le député à quoi vra
des bêtises Contin monsieur ministre
refondre du statut des repentistes en
cours
plusieurs députés seront évidemment
associés à ce texte il est important il
est attendu président marcangéi
président sachaoulier
voilà on
veut on veut s'inspirer de ce que font
les Italiens voilà mais som pas encore
pour dire les choses prêt bon la
grasque proposition de loi qui pourrait
élargir davantage les missions de la
grasque je rappelle que on a augmenté
considérablement le budget et les moyens
de la grensque 45 ETP en 2020 83 en 23
85 % de personnel en
plus création d'antennes régional
Marseille Lyon Lille Ren Bordeaux fort-
de- France et une hausse de des
confiscations enfin quand même de 100
% voilà entre 2020 et 2022 pour
atteindre 171 millions ur d'avoir
criminels qui vont abonder le budget de
l'État
voilà enfin Mayotte la deuxème prison
alors c'est à vous monsieur le député à
qu mais c'est aussi mais bien sûr mais
bien
sûr nous avons budgeté on attend un
terrain donnez-moi un terrain on
construit pas inverser les choses je
l'ai dit déjà lorsque je suis allé à
Mayotte parce que j'ai constaté
évidemment que c'était une nécessité
mais je vous promets vous me donnez un
coup de fil vous me dites monsieur le
ministre j'ai le terrain si
naturellement il est constructible et et
avec bien sûr les caractéristiques
techniques idoines que la Piche va
déterminer on y va on peut pas être plus
clair voilà on peut pas vous dire mieux
et ensuite et enfin Madame Ménard qui a
fait son
petit dialogue de gestion en direct
voilà sans complexe bon madame Ménard je
vais vous dire les choses très vite au
siège un poste vacante VP sur 25 postes
se magistrats placés auprès de la cour
d'appel qui peuvent être mobilisés par
le premier président le parquet il y a
un poste de vice-procureur vacant sur un
effectif de Neu parquetiers C magistrat
à noté quand même placé au parquet de la
cour d'appel qui peuvent être mobilisés
plus alors en matière de fonctionnaire
et de greffe 92 agents plus 2 en surnom
soit 94 agents et d'ici 2027 la cour
d'appel de Montpellier plus 52
magistrats plus 41 greffiers plus 40
attachés de justice qui vont arriver et
qui seront finement répartis
oui ils seront finement répartis par les
chefs de
cours non mais faites pas un c'est c'est
c'est la l'obgie ça hein voilà bon
euh donc ça va puis on va on va on va
dire aussi une autre chose je je le dis
les Jeux Olympiques vont mobiliser
évidemment beaucoup de magistrats sur
les sites Paris Versailles bobini région
parisienne Marseille
Lyon bon alors j'ai 10 insrit on
n'arrivera pas à passer avant la
suspension pour aller voter euh la
motion de rejet préalable du PLFSS donc
jeisen prendre quelquesunes et je
suspendrai madame Caroline yadent on
prendra naturellement après hein vous en
faites pas je vous remercie monsieur le
Président euh monsieur le ministes les
modes alternatifs de règlement des
différents tels que la médiation le
processus collaboratif mais aussi les
rencontres restauratives sont
susceptible vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
de contribuer largement à l'apaisement
de la société à l'heure où la violence
verbale symbolique et physique est
devenue un mode d'expression courant
dans notre société et même dans
l'hémicycle il est essentiel de
retrouver les moyens de dialoguer
d'échanger d'entendre de converser de
comprendre d'expliquer de son confronté
en
définitive de communiquer pour aboutir à
des échanges
pacifiés c'est un moyen vous l'avez dit
également monsieur le ministre pour le
justiciable de se réapproprier et son
procès de rendre une justice plus proche
et plus rapide nous devons nous inscrire
comme les chefs de fil de la
transformation de la justice pour
qu'elle soit plus inclusive moins
coûteuse plus pacifiée et qu'elle ne
laisse personne de
côté la médiation est un mode alternatif
de règlement des différents et nous
devons soutenir le recours à cette
médiation pourtant l'aide
juridictionnelle prévue en cas de
médiation conventionnel et conditionné à
un ordre du juge en d'autres termes
monsieur le ministre lorsque des partis
souhaitent mettre en place une médiation
sans aucune intervention du juge en
présence d'avocat ces derniers les
avocats ne peuvent pas être indemnisés
au titre de l'aide juridictionnelle
alors même que leur interventions
peuvent être déterminantes dans la
résolution du conflit de leurs clients
voici ma question monsieur le ministre
peut-être que vous l'avez deviné comment
pouvons-nous inciter à l'utilisation de
la médiation conventionnelle alors même
que les avocats il participent qui
participent n'obtiennent pas de
rétribution lorsqu'ils assistent une
partie éligible à cette même aide
juridictionnelle je vous remercie madame
Pascale
borde merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre la lutte contre les
violent les violences sexistes et
sexuelles a été érigé par le Président
de la République au rang de grandes
causes du quinquena au grand mot les
grands remèdes et aux grandes causes on
aurait pu penser que viendrai les gros
budgets malheureuse
la réalité est tout autre car en guise
de grand planans de lutte nous affichons
46,5 petits millions d'euros de budget
global pour l'aide aux victimes
d'infraction pénale juste 2 millions de
plus que la loi de finances 2023 c'est
juste une goutte d'eau dans un océan de
violence surtout lorsque l'on voit qu'en
Espagne le budget alloué uniquement à la
lutte contre les violences fait aux
femmes s'est élevé depuis 2021 à 748
millions d'euros par an dans un pays
significativement moins peuplé que la
France en France malgré le Grenel des
violences conjugales malgré les campagne
de sensibilisation malgré des avancées
incontestables dans la prise en charge
des victimes malgré des avancées
procédurales telles que l'ordonnance de
protection le nombre de fémidicides
continue d'augmenter avec une envolée
record en 2022 mais plus inquiétant
encore c'est la très forte augmentation
des tentatives de féminicide plus 45 %
de 20 22 côté espagnol le nombre de
féminicides a baissé de 25 % depuis 2004
aujourd'hui les femmes espagnoles ont
sont deux fois moins nombreuses à mourir
sous les coups de leurs compagnons que
les femmes françaises il est vrai que
l'Espagne a su se dotté très tôt en 2004
d'une loi cadre et d'un budget
conséquent à la hauteur de l'ampleur de
la tâche le système espagnol n'est
certes pas parfait c'est vrai mais il
est incontestablement en avance sur le
système franis
qui emprunte peu ou prou certains des
procès qui ont déjà fait leur preuve en
Espagne tels les téléphones grav danger
ou les bracelets antirapprochement mais
à une échelle bien moindre il est temps
de rattraper enfin notre retard et de
passer à un stade qui permette la
réalisation à grande échelle d'où ma
question madame Toria pour 2
minutes ça vous
et merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre il y a quelques mois vous
vous félicitiez d'avoir obtenu un budget
historique pour la justice et au même
moment la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme condamna la France une fois de
plus pour ses conditions indignes de
détention quelle image de la justice ce
budget porte-t-il quand on observe que
la partie la plus importante est
consacrée à l'administration
pénitentiaire au point de représenter si
cette fois celui de l'accès au droits et
à la justice vision du tout carcéral en
écho avec la logique du tout répressive
de votre collègue d'armanin je vous le
redis plus on construit plus on enferme
vous auriez pu consacrer cette hausse de
budget à l'embuche de SPIP à la
formation des surveillants
pénitentiaires plutôt que de généraliser
les caméras piétons et d'introduire des
caméras de vidéosurveillance
intelligente 5 milliards de dettes pour
une fuite en avant monsieur le ministre
il y a 2 semaines je me suis rendue dans
la maison d'arrêt de lyoncba puis au
centre pénitentiaire de Saint-Quentin
Fallavier je suis entrée dans les cellu
du quartier arrivant censé respecter le
principe d'encellulement individuel à
même de réduire l'intensité du choc
carcéral elles étaient toutes
surpeuplées je suis entrée dans la
maison d'arrêt pour femm de liyon CORBA
incroyable elle était surpeuplée les
surveillants m'ont dit que la semaine
d'avant trois matelas au sol avaient été
rajoutés en urgence monsieur le ministre
quand allez-vous mettre fin à votre
politique coûteuse du tout carcéral
inutile pour l'insertion et la lutte
contre la récidive quand allez-vous
cesser de jeter l'argent public par les
fenêtres quand allez-vous faire adopter
ce mécanisme de régulation carcérale que
les professionnels de la justice
réclament depuis des années et qui ne
vient
jamais merci pour la réponse
monsieursour après on
suspend merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
monsieur le ministre tout à l'heure vous
avez dit que votre euh trajectoire votre
but c'est d'aller être plus proche et
avoir une justice plus rapide s'agissant
des maillottes et parce qu'il faut faire
vite je vous propose comme je l'avais
proposé l'année dernière d'avoir un plan
global comme je l'ai proposé à votre
prédécesseur parce que on est à 30
années lumière par rapport à la justice
telle qu'elle est vécu sur le reste du
territoire
euh nous avons dit vous êtes venu vous
avez vous nous avez promis une cité J
judiciaire vous avez pris une prison
vous avez pris un centre ainsi de suite
aujourd'hui rien y fait je vous entends
vous me dit il n'y a pas de foncier
ailleurs quand il y a pas de foncier
monsieur le ministre au cas vous le Saez
pas on fait une DUP on exproprie mais à
Mayotte moi je prends la resp la la la
la représentation nationale à témoin
faites faites-m venir le le le
euh le responsable du SPIP et on va
chercher le terrain lui et moi on
trouvera le terrain et on fera tout ça
pour vous dire euh que nous avons je
vous l'avais dit encore l'année dernière
nous avons
5 nous avons qu'est-ce que je dis 5000
actes d'état civil qui attendent un juge
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez trouvé
l'année dernière vous avez dit il y aura
une brigade oui c'est vrai merci vous
nous avez envoyé une brigade mais une
brigade de euh euh comment dit Syndicat
de la magistrature qui est venu nous
apprendre que Maette n'était pas
française c'est la seule chose qu'ils
ont trouvé que Maette n'était pas
française et qu'il fallait le rendre au
Comor voilà voilà la réalité monsieur le
ministre donc moi je souhaite
effectivement que qu'il n'y ait il n'y a
pas de il n'y a pas de suffisamment
d'officiers ministériels de notaires
ainsi de suite par conséquent je vous
demande un véritable plan global qui
prend tous les aspects de la question
judiciire parce que les mauris méritent
comme les autres avoir la même justice
avec les mêmes moyens pour
qu'effectivement nous soyons comme les
autres traités comme des vrais citoyens
de la République avec une justice qui
marche et qui est debouts bien il a
raison on suspend et on reprend dans 5 à
10 minutes le temps de voter sur la
motion
préalable commence par madame Béatrice
roulau vous avez la parole pour 2
minutes madame rouleau
allez-y monsieur le
ministre vous connaissez ma volonté de
mieux lutter contre la maltraitance
infantile je suis souvent intervenu sur
le sujet en hémicycle et ma première
question posée au gouvernement pait
d'ailleurs sur les moyens de la détecter
si l'on en croit les chiffres de
l'association l'enfant bleu deux enfants
meurent par jour en France des suites de
maltraitance il est nécessaire en
conséquence d'orienter le budget de
l'État vers le développement de moyens
donné à la justice pour enrayer ce
chiffre ainsi pourrions-nous déjà
flécher le budget de l'État en direction
de deux mesures recommandées par de
nombreuses associations et inséré dans
le programme de Marine Le Pen la
première la Constitution dans chaque
département d'une équipe chargée de
l'évaluation de l'enfant ceci afin
d'éviter la trop grande proximité des
services sociaux avec les familles qu'il
suivent et le conflit d'intérêts ou de
loyauté pouvant naître lorsqu'il s'agit
de dénoncer des parents
bourreaux la seconde mesure la
désignation automatique d'un avocat dans
toute procédure pénale voire civile
ville concernant un mineur car
aujourd'hui il faut le savoir il existe
encore des cas où aucun avocat n'est
désigné pour assister l'enfant lorsque
ses parents sont soupçonnés de
maltraitance il faut donc une
automaticité de la désignation de
l'avocat pour le mineur bien sûr si
cette mesure essentielle était prise
alors les moyens de l'aide
juridictionnel devrait être
singulièrement augmenté ma question sera
simple monsieur le ministre êtes-vous
prêt à faire à ce
sujet merci Monsieur
rot monsieur le Président Monsieur le le
ministre deux questions pour préciser
deux plans la première ça a été déjà
rappelé par madamemerer concernant les
CF alors pour la sonelir vous avez très
précisément répondu mais globalement
pour le développement des centres
éducatifs fermés quel est le rythme et
quel est votre projet parce que nous y
sommes très attachés on pense que tant
qu'il y a une solution éducative il faut
pouvoir jouer cette carte là pour les
mineurs et donc éviter la la prison
j'allais dire automatiquement sauf
évidemment si la situation finit par ne
pas s'arranger si j'ose dire mais
vraiment ça fait partie du panel des
substituts à la à la prison et donc nous
y sommes extrêmement favorables deuxème
élément pour les cours départementales
de justice la loi qui a été votée qui
fera date précise qu'il y aura donc une
généralisation d'une certaine manière du
dispositif là encore quel est le rythme
quelles échéances nous pouvons retenir
en la matière merci à vous merci
Monsieur Philippe goselin merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre
forcément quand on arrive au second tour
des questions un certain nombre de
sujets ont déjà été évoqués on a un
budget qui en effet dans la continuité
de la loi de programmation et dans ce
cadre là on peut s'en s'en réjouir bien
sûr mais avec aussi ce petit bémol comme
je l'avais dit lors des explications de
vote pour le groupe les les républicains
un peu trompeleœuil avec l'inflation
ceci étant ça concerne tous les budgets
et pas simplement le budget de de de la
justice j'en conviens aisément mais
c'est un petit sujet de préoccupation si
ça devait se se poursuivre trois trois
sujets d'importance en ce qui me me
concern la première concernant les les
les recrutements j'ai pas de difficulté
évidemment avec ce qui est mis en place
je l'ai voté dans la loi de
programmation on se réjouit d'avoir plus
de greffi de magistrats de gardiens de
prison bien évidemment mais quelle
mesure entendez-vous mettre en avant et
pas nécessairement financière du reste
pour essayer de de capter l'attention
pour capitaliser c'est l'attractivité
finalement de toutes ces professions
comment garder les talents alors qu'il y
a un turnover très important notamment
chez les gardiens de de de prison euh
une difficulté de recrutement aussi dans
d'autres professions donc voilà ça
dépasse les stricts aspect budgétaires
que vous avez évoqué qui sont importants
mais comment faire et c'est pas
simplement sur 2024 c'est aussi dans la
dans les années suivantes inquiétude sur
l'effectivité aussi des
constructions de prison le plan 15000
que nous nous appelons plan 18000 sans
doute un peu facile de renvoyer les élus
locaux dans leurs demandes et leurs
autorisations c'est vrai qu'on a parfois
certaines réticences mais pas que et moi
je note quand même que le budget
d'investissement euh cette année est
quand même assez limité et et qu'il
faudrait essayer de donner un coup
d'accélérateur euh sans doute avec les
élus locaux mais peut-être aussi avec
une volonté clairement affichée du du
ministère enfin un dernier point c'est
sur la j qui'est cher comme vous le
savez euh on a effectivement une
augmentation
importante ces dernières années mais ça
patine un peu cette année l'année
prochaine on a deux fois moins
d'augmentation que l'inflation elle-même
donc avec des vrais sujets et j'aimerais
que que vous nous donniez pour terminer
la la politique pour les années à venir
en matière d'accès au droitsci monsieur
Romin
maobri merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je veux vous
alerter une fois de plus sur la
situation sécuritaire des établissements
pénitentiaires la commission d'enquête
parlementaire chargé de mettre en
lumière les dysfonctionnements de
l'administration suite au Morts d'Ivan
Colona app pointé les nombreuses
défaillances outre le manque de
personnel le manque de moyens pour
assurer la sécurité des agents des
détenus et des structures est réel je
PLA pour les extension des systèmes de
vidéoprotection et incluant de
l'intelligence artificielle afin d'aider
l'agent chargé de visualiser parfois
près de 300 caméas je plaide pour la
généralisation de filets au-dessus des
cours de promenade et des terrains de
sport afin d'empêcher les projections et
les drones également la création
d'établissement spécifiqu en fonction
des profils des détenus avec une gestion
ultra sécuritaire pour les détenus
radicalisé et aujourd'hui le compte n
est pas je me demande quand va devoir
survenir un nouveau drame pour que le
ministère se décide enfin à agir suite à
l'assassinat à d'an Cologne il avait été
annoncé que les agents seraient formés à
l'usage de caméras de vidéo protection
j'ai eu l'occasion lors de récente
visite dans des ablissement pénitentia
notamment en Corse de constater que
cette formation n'avait pas été
généralisée et que les agents derrière
les écrans qui dans le même temps
effectuent de nombreuses autres tâches
n'osaient toujours pas les manipuler et
ce budget qui annonce un recul de du
budget consacré à la formation n'annonce
rien de glorieux la sécurité de nos
prisons est préoccupante si elle n'est
pas assurée c'est bien l'ensemble des
français qui est sont en danger car si
on s'évade avec explosif et hélicoptère
en 20223 on s'évade aussi lors de
promenade en forêt ou en siant les
barreaux de sa cellule en utilisant des
draps alors ma question est est simple
monsieur le ministre quand comptez-vous
instaurer sécurité et autorité dans les
établissements pénitentiaires de notre
pays je vous remercie monsieur Timothé o
ça merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je voulais vous interpeller
sur le programme de construction de
15000 places de prisons supplémentaires
à l'issue de ce programme c'est
c'est-à-dire d'après les promesses du
gouvernement en 2027 75000 places
devaent être opérationnel pour un coût
global annoncé de 4,5 milliards d'euros
pour rappel la France compte 73800
personnes détenues à l'été 2023 un
chiffre que les prévisions estiment à la
hausse dans ce projet de loi de finan
vous nous annoncez la création de
2771 places nettes depuis 2018 mais
comme l'a dévoilé le rapport
parlementaire de Monsieur Patrick Etzel
en mai 2023 2081 places ouvertes depuis
2018 relève en réalité d'autres
programmes de construction mis en place
par les gouvernements qui vous ont
précédé ensuite votre plan 15000 qui
devient de fait un plan 13000 a pris du
retard comme vous l'avez expliqué au
début de ce mois notamment en raison du
covid et de la guerre en Ukraine la
mission justice de ce projet de loi de
finance 2024 nous indique 36 opérations
restantes à livrer au sein du programme
15000 places mais 13 d'entre elles n'en
sont encore qu'au stade des études
préalables aujourd'hui pouvez-vous nous
indiquer si ces établissements ouvriront
comme prévu à l'horizon 2027 ou si
compte tenu du retard prix cette
échéance est repoussée et à quand
combien de places seront effectivement
construites pour 2027 pouvez-vous
également nous communiquer les surcûts
liés à ce retard et au-udelà des retards
parlons aussi des conséquences de retard
parce que nous constatons qu'au face au
manque de place de prison les jugements
limitent les incarcérations ce weekend
et ce n'est qu'un exemple dans un
hôpital d'Argenteuil deux femmes de 93
et 95 ans ont été agressés sexuellement
puis sont décédés dans les heures ou
jours qui ont suivi le suspect déjà
connu des services de police pour des
faits similaires a été relâché et placé
sous contrôle judiciaire malgré les
réquisitions du parquet aujourd'hui le
manque de place de prison nu au
placement détation provisoire d'individu
dangereux pour nos concitoyens en
conséquence étant donné que les places
nécessaires au seul détenus actuel ne
seront pas construites avant 5 à 10 ans
quelle mesure d'urgence peut-être
provisoire prévoyez-vous pour assurer
l'exécution des peines et la possibilité
de placer les personnes qu' nécessitent
en détention provisoire monsieur le
ministre pour réponse à ces questions
oui
d'abord madame la députée Caroline
yadam merci pour l'investissement qui
est le vôtre en matière en matière
d'amiable et je le dis vous savez de
quoi vous parlez parce que vous es par
ailleurs une professionnelle du droit
bon oui
on revalorise l'agis des avocats qui
recourent à l'amiable pour à hauteur de
8 millions d'euros par
an
mais l'incitation des avocatourir à
l'amiable ne repose pas que sur l'agi
parce que il y a des avocats qui vont
intervenir dans dans des dossiers dans
lequel ils vont pas demander le bénéfice
de l'agie ou ce sera impossible
évidemment donc on envisage et vous êtes
bien placé pour le savoir des actions de
communication euh on renforce avec les
les avocats la formation à
l'amable on mobilise les ambassadeurs de
l'amiable qui vont aller et ils ont déjà
commencé ce travail dans toutes les
cours d'appel j'ai oublié tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs quand j'ai décliné un peu
quand j'ai défini un peu ce qui étaaiit
les ambassadeurs de l'amiable j'ai
oublié le corps enseignant corps
professoral ça n'est pas rien donc on a
des enseignants on a des avocats on a
des magistrats on a des commissaires de
justice on a des notaires ça entre en
vigueur à compté du 1er novembre on va
faire une grande campagne de publicité
on constate à l'étranger je l' dis que
c'est le mode de règlement le plus usité
que ça rapproche le citoyen de sa
justice que c'est rendu dans des délais
beaucoup plus courts que ça replace le
juge dans son cœur de métier c'était
quelque chose qui était exprimé
fortement notamment dans la tribune des
3000 mais ça permet aussi au justici
able d'être de se réapproprier son
procès rendez compte que dans certaines
procédures 2 ans et demi 3 ans de mise
en état le justiciable ne voit jamais
son juge mais comment on peut aimer la
justice si elle est désincarnée bamiable
c'est le contraire de cela donc on va
prendre effectivement un certain nombre
de
dispositions
notamment financière l'agit pour
valoriser l'amiable et il faut aussi
convaincre les avocats qui ne sont pas
àagie que c'est un modèle économique qui
est viable parce que naturellement on
traite beaucoup plus de dossiers et il
ressort des différentes rencontres que
j'ai pu faire et j'en ai euh j'en ai
fait beaucoup qu'en réalité non
seulement alors c'est un modèle
économique viable pour les avocats parce
qu'il traitent davantage de dossier
parce que les délais sont réduits parce
qu'en terme d'honoraire de résultat ils
peuvent être plus plus chers tout tout
simplement parce que ça marche plus vite
que ça fonctionne bien
et voilà il y a une véritable dynamique
qui qui démarre qui va dans le bon sens
moi vous savez à quel point je suis
engagé sur cette question comme vous et
je pense que si tout le monde s'y met on
va imposer laamable comme mode de
règlement des litiges et tout le monde
me dit que les litiges les plus
complexes se résolvent mieux par
l'amiable que par le contentieux parce
que tout le monde a intérêt à ne pas
aller d'expertise en contre expertise et
cetera et cetera et ETA tout le monde a
intérêt à l'amiable et si on arrive à
convaincre tout le monde on va réussir
ce Paris de réduire les délais en
matière civile et de les diminuer par de
et ça n'est tout de même pas rien madame
bord budget alloué voilà budget alloué
aux
victimes passe de 47 millions
euh va passer à 47 millions en 2024
c'est une hausse de 2 millions par
rapport à 2023 et sur l'autre point de
de préoccupation le budget annuel qui
est alloué à la lutte contre les
violences intrafamiliales est en
augmentation importante avec plus d'un
doublement entre 2020 et 2024 de 8
million d'euros en 2020 à 17,2 million
d'euros dans le budget 24 et ce que vous
dites sur l'Espagne est juste ils ont
été beaucoup plus rapides que nous sur
ces questions vous l'avez dit 2004 mais
il faut dire aussi quand on regarde euh
les féminicides en Espagne que il a
fallu un certain temps pour ne pas dire
un temps certain avant que la courbe des
féminicides s'infléchisse et
sérieusement ils ont eu un premier
plateau ça a drastiquement diminué et
ils sont aujourd'hui sur un deuxème
plateau parce que moi je veux bien que
pardon oui j' j'entends bien ils sont
mis en place bien avant nous ils ont été
précurseurs à plein d'égard il y a des
sujets il y a des sujets sur lesquels
nous n'avons pas à rougir je pense bar
téléphone grave danger et cetera et je
vous remercie d'ailleurs je vous
remercie parce que je l'ai entendu dans
votre question de le dire avec beaucoup
d'objectivité maintenant il y a des gens
on se dit les choses moi le risque zéro
ça n'est pas possible pour moi parce que
je suis au manette laissez-moi terminer
c'est un petit coup de patte que je vous
adresse ce n'est pas possible pour moi
le risque zéro parce que je suis un
manette mais il y a des gens vous pouvez
leur mettre quatre bracelets enti
rapprochement ils commettront c'est une
réalité et la baguette magique pour
qu'il y ait plus de délinquence c'est ce
que j'en pense j'ai eu Moutte fois
l'occasion de de de m'expliquer de
m'expliquer là-dessus donc on progresse
encore et et et regardez il y a eu le le
le rapport de vos deux collègues
Dominique Verrien et Madame qui qui qui
était qui suit ces choses avec beaucoup
d'intérêt euh de ce rapport on tire quoi
une ordonnance de protection qui va être
prise dans quelques heures il fallait
être équilibré et assurer bien sûr un
volet contradictoire parce que sinon
nous étions dans quelque chose
d'arbitraire enfin d'une certaine façon
et puis ensuite il y a la mise en place
des pôles spécialisés ilelles ont
entendu 400 témoins c'est un vrai boulot
on a pris ça évidemment en considér
parce que le travail parlementaire quand
il est fait de cette façon il doit
forcément nous nourrir en tous les cas
nourrir le ministre que que je suis
monsieur
camardine je n'ai pas envoyé comme vous
l'avez
dit j'ai envoyé brigade magistrat et
greffier mais j'ai pas envoyé des gens
qu quand vous avez dit du Syndicat de la
magistrature moi je demande pas la carte
de syndicaliste au magistrats qui sont
partis là-bas et puis j'os espérer voyez
que
mais
oui mais j'ai entendu ce que vous avez
dit Monsieur goselin mais j'ose quand
même espérer que la boussole et c'est
une réalité pour moi du magistrat c'est
l'effet le droit oui oui à la fête de
l'humain aussi mais là à la je m'are je
m'are non mais à la fête de l'humain si
vous voulez non mais à la fête de
l'umain monsieur monsieur le député
gostin j'ai dit vertement ce que je
pensais d'un certain nombre de prises de
position
et j'ai
pas non non vous m'avez beaucoup entend
ça fait 3 He qu'on est en édition je P
vous m'avez beaucoup entendu et certains
ont souligné que pe Gard des saau avait
dit avec cette verdeur qui est parfois
la mienne ce que j'ai dit
maintenan sur
Mayot sur Mayotte il y a plusieurs
opérations immobilières qui ont été
lancées monsieur
camardine grâce au conseil départemental
on a pu acquérir le terrain pour la
future cité judiciaire ça a été discuté
je suis parti à Mayotte j'ai rencontré
le président du conseil départemental
c'est un dossier qui traînait depuis
Bellet comme quoi ça sert parfois les
visites ministériel et puis quand les
bonnes volontés s'unissent on finit par
faire quelque chose et et et et nous
sommes en train de le faire donc on a pu
acquérir le terrain de la future cité
judiciaire centre éducatif fermé tant
attendu localement sera en gestion
publique vous savez non pas associative
l'État doit s'impliquer évidemment à
Mayot et nous avons identifier un
terrain bon j'ai déjà parlé de la
deuxème prison donnez-moi un coup de
main ah oui mais d'accord mais ça ça me
fait pas construire une prison bon vous
prenez rendez-vous ensuite et comme
ça ah ben ok mais moi je je suis preneur
je vous ai dit que c'était déjà budgeté
bon madame
madame madame Tor bon vous dites
toujours les mêmes choses
c'est oui oui mais sans doute mais moi
je dis des choses vraies c'est ça la
différence c'est plus supportable euh
parce que quand vous redites que on a
tout consacré au pénite c'est absolument
faux je l'ai dit il y a quelques minutes
vous voulez pas l'entendre peu importe
bon euh et puis je vais vous dire il y a
une espèce de théorème chez vous vous
savez d'axiome la différence entre le
théorème et l'axiome c'est que l'axiome
c'est indémontrable donc vous assinez ça
vous dites plus on construit de place et
plus on les remplit ah bon donc faut non
mais madame je termine je termine
pardonnez-moi je termine euh je vous ai
pas interrompu
euh ça m'a coûté un peu d'ailleurs mais
souffrez que je vous réponde euh madame
euh moi je vois pas comment on peut
régler la question de la surpopulation
pénal sans utiliser ce levier de la
construction de la construction de la
réhabilitation ce que vous ne dites pas
c'est que dans les établissements qu'on
construit ou qu'on rénove par exemple il
y a des douches individuelles par
cellule moi moi j'ai connu l'époque la
justice je la connais bien en j'ai j'ai
cette prétention de la connaître bien en
tous les cas de façon effective moi j'ai
connu l'époque où il y avait une douche
par semaine et je veux dire quelque
chose c'était d'abord dégradant c'était
inhumain et en plus et ça existe encore
malheureusement et en plus ça m'etttait
en et je vois que Monsieur bauder opine
et Monsieur bauder ne me démentira pas
si je dis que c'est le moment l'un des
moments les plus dangereux pour le
personnel
pénitentiaire voilà bon donc que on a
quand même fait un certain nombre de
choses vous vous ne reconnaissez jamais
rien de ce que l'on peut améliorer je
veux dire également que dans la loi de
programmation réforme pour la justice il
y a une hausse
des je veux parler de ça des LSC qu'on a
mis en place 1563 au 1er juillet 22
contre 771 au 1er juillet 2019 et puis
une politique volontariste
d'optimisation du parc immobilier et un
transfert accéléré pour les condamnés
vers les établissements pour peine ce
que
apportéit le président de la commission
des Lois du Sénat François Noël buffet
et et et et nous avons effectivement
soutenu ce texte voilà ce que je
voudrais vous dire
[Musique]
ensuite monsieur Rémi riberotte le voilà
Monsieur le Député TR CF ont déjà été
ouverts et sont aujourd'hui
comptabilisés dans les 53 en
fonctionnement
éperné Bergerac saint-nazer et 19 seront
livrés d'ici la fin du quinquena 3 en
2024 Rochefort le vernis en Ariège
moncinerie tonegrande en Guyane 5 en
2025 les amilices
céar belle béangreville
Calvados apte vauclus Bleret indréloir
digne dans les Alpes de ha Provence 3 en
26 Lure maotte villenuve Loubé 8 en 27
voilà ce que nous
comptons construire pour être j'allais
dire dans les clous pardon des promesses
qui ont été faites par le Président de
la
République Monsieur goselin monsieur
goselin sur
l'inflation merci de dire les choses
avec avec beaucoup de Nuan je pense déjà
avoir
sur les
18000 18000
15000 vous savez moi moi moi je demande
pas mieux que de ne pas
rencontrer sur ces questions de de de
terrain parce que c'est c'est ça au fond
je souhaite vraiment de tout cœur ne pas
rencontrer
d'obstacle alors vous avez dit c'est un
peu facile mais je veux être tout à fait
clair avec vous c'est peut-être un peu
facile mais c'est vrai en même temps on
les connaît les endroits où ça bloque
bon moi j'aimerais que ça se débloque
j'ai dit à Eric cotti on a beaucoup
discuté vous le savez vous étiez là
vous-même vous vous vous avez apporté
votre votre pierre à la construction
pénitentiaire si j'ose dire à l'édifice
en tous les cas euh moi je pense et je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure vous étiez
totalement sincère je le suis aussi
donnez-nous un coup de main et et on va
réussir à les faire moi je pense que
c'est utile bon c'est pas pour être plus
répressif c'est pour assurer la dignité
des conditions de détention et davantage
de sécurité et de confort pour un
personnel pénitentiaire qui le mérite
voilà je suis allé je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure inaugurer qu if on est parti on
a fait une visite c'était l'ancienne
prison totalement dégradée et puis la
nouvelle bon c'est le jour et la nuit
moi je je je je
n'ai aucun aucun frein idéologique en
tous les cas à ce que l'on construise
des établissements dignes euh dans une
grande démocratie la détention doit être
un lieu de privation de liberté de
punition mais aussi un lieu de de de
possible réinsertion tout ça je pense
qu'on pense exactement la même chose
donc donnez-nous un coup de main et on
sera au rendez-vous de de je notre
rapport annexé et et du texte qu'on a
construit ensemble bon sur les
recrutements de magistrats je l'ai dit
la difficulté elle est là moi je me
cache pas derrière mon petit doigt mais
comment on peut régler ça campagne de
communication c'est très important
donner des informations claires sur les
carrières les informations métier aller
en parler dans les universités et et le
4è levier c'est ouvrir mais ça on l'a
fait ensemble j'allais dire c'est ouvrir
les passerelles pour que des professions
du droit qui souhaitaient intégrer la
magistrature et qui étaient rebuté
notamment par la longueur des stage la
complexité il y avait je sais plus
combien il y avait se SEP voies d'accès
on a drastiquement réduit tout ça on a
simplifié tout ça en plus ça permet une
ouverture du corps et moi je suis très
favorable à l'ouverture du corps je l'ai
dit depuis le le le le premier jour donc
voilà les leviers qui sont les nôtres
madame roulau madame Roulot on fait
beaucoup sur le sujet de l'enfance
maltraitée vous savez que j'ai lancé et
je vous su très attentive à cela en
février le programme pamivie programme
d'accompagnement du mineur victime
France victime déploie un programme
d'accompagnement des mineurs dans la
découverte par exemple de la salle
d'assise on est allé chercher ça au
Québec pour que les petits enfants qui
appréhendent le moment du procès un
moment terrible euh puisse circuler dans
la salle d'audience voir une robe de
magistrat euh monter sur le fa voilà ça
c'est très très important et on nous a
beaucoup parlé de ça on a été séduit par
ça les chiens d'assistance judiciaire en
moi j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai vu ce que ça
donnait j'ai entendu des enquêteurs dire
moi je peux plus m'en
passer parce que ça libère la parole des
gamins et juge d'instruction aussi pour
dire ça change tout on nous a donné de
multiples exemples j'avais fait un
déplacement avec Brigitte Macron euh on
avait vu les les les chiens on avait
expertisé tout ça dans une juridiction
un tribunal judiciaire et tous nos
interlocuteurs disaient c'est une
avancée donc ça se développe ça se
multiplie on avait un petit problème
budgétaire parce que ça coûtait très
cher à l'origine on pensait qu'il
fallait des chiens d'aveugle mais le
dressage d'un chien d'aveugle coûte très
cher on a réduit un peu le dressage
voilà on veut des chien gentils bien
élevés bien dressé doux avec les enfants
qui savent
ils vont pas grimper sur le gamin ils
posent leur tête et le gamin il a une
espèce de petit doudou vivant là et ça
libère ça par c'est extraordinaire de le
voir c'est très intéressant je vous le
développer partout les les uaped
évidemment vous savez bien sont sont
sont des lieux c'est c'est c'est c'est
un endroit formidable on recueille une
fois la parole du gamin il y a une prise
en charge sanitaire hélas c'est parfois
nécessaire et il y a il y a il y a vous
me troublez madame
huntermerer il il y a prise en charge
sanitaire psychologique psychiatrique
médical judiciaire évidemment donc on
avance sur ces questions on a encore à
l'évidence beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
faire monsieur Baudri bon je je je veux
quand même vous rappeler parce que je
sais bien qu'un morceau avallé n'a plus
de saveur mais
2021 les moyens alloués à la
sécurisation des établissements
pénitentiaires sont portés à 70 millions
d'EUR c'est + 9 % par rapport à 2020
2022 la dotation allouée s'élève à
118,5 million d'euros dont une dotation
exceptionnelle de 30 millions dans le
cadre de la sécurisation périmétrique
des établissements pénitentiaires sur
l'exercice 2023 76,9 million
programmation de déploiement de
dispositif de brouillage lutte antidrone
déploiement déploiement du programme
d'AP mobilité vous savez évidemment ce
que c'est quant à la sécurité
sécurisation des enceintes
pénitentiaires les rénovations
impliquent un un financement de près de
22 millions 2024 c'est
83,7 millions de hausse alors caméra
piéton généralisé brouillage des
téléphone dispositif antidrone
vidéosurveillance en détention
smartphone alarme sago amélioration de
la sécurité des systèmes
d'information généralisation du port de
la caméra individuelle poursuite du plan
de lutte contre les violences lancées je
veux vous dire une chose Monsieur le
Député on ne modifie pas les choses en
un claquement de doigt moi je n'ai pas
de baguette magique c'est facile quand
on est dans l'opposition de dire Yaka
faucon faudrait je vous ai donner là la
liste des améliorations et si vous êtes
intellectuellement honnête ce dont je ne
peux pas douter vous allez quand même
nous concéder que des choses ont été
nettement améliorées enfin monsieur
Timothé housoussin bon moi je vais vous
dire mais je je je je je vous ai déjà
donneré un certain nombre d'explications
sur la loi de programmation je je vais
pas les reprendre je pense que j'ai la
faiblesse de penser que vous avez été
attentif mais arrêtez de grâce de
prendre une affaire que personne ne
connaît pas plus vous que les autres
d'ailleurs pour dire la justice a mal
fait son job je vais vous dire quelque
chose entendez-le la démocratie c'est
l'état de droit non mais écoutez-moi 2
secondes c'est des notions qui ne sont
pas superfitatoires et l'état de droit
c'est l'indépendance de la justice alors
moi vous me parlez d'un dossier je le
connais pas et vous assinez que les
peines qui ont été retenus ne sont pas
les peines que l'on aurait dû retenir et
d'un dossier qui fait peut-être 50 cm de
hauteur vous le résumez à deux phrases
ça n'est pas correct ça monsieur ne pas
respecter la justice qui est notre pacte
social c'est délé terire c'est délé
terire et si un jour vous arrivez au
pouvoir il y a deux solutions
vous laissez notre justice totalement
indépendante faire son travail et vous
pourrez critiquer telle ou telle
décision ou vous la mettez au pas ce que
les Hongrois ont fait je les ai reçu moi
les magistrats hongrois même tentative
chez les Polonais les Polonais ont
choisi après avoir choisi un
régime plutôt très à droite de revenir
vers quelque chose qui est davantage euh
euh la sensibilité qui est la mienne
donc attention à ces trucsl arrêtez de
dire qu'elle est laxiste arrêtez c'est
pas vrai euh la Cour des comptes le dit
arrêtez de faire votre miel de cela
parce que si vous êtes un jour au
pouvoir je vous dis quelque chose
écoutez-moi je le souhaite pas vous le
savez mais franchement je vous donne pas
une semaine sans que vous ayez votre lot
d'un action de criis vous faites la même
chose sur tout monsieur le député le
terrorisme le droit commun le vous avez
vous avez toutes les solutions clé en
main ben c'est pas vrai c'est pas comme
ça que ça marche je vais vous dire
quelque chose il y a un professeur de
droit qui disait le droit pénal c'est le
droit de l'échec parce que quand la
justice est saisie monsieur le mal est
déjà fait il faut que vous l'entendiez
si un jour vous allez au pouvoir si vous
conquéit démocratiquement et
bien vous verrez que je ne dis pas de
bêtises d'ailleurs parlez-en aux avocats
qui sont dans votre groupe je pense
qu'ils vous diront pas le contraire de
ce que je vous ai
dit c'est terminé merci beaucoup et on
se retrouve à 21h30 pour l'examen des
amendements